Bom,
bom five four three two,
one.
We're live here from the valley with the
artist formerly known as the amazing
atheist.
Hello.
If I just started talking like that,
no explanation.
I just kept it going for years.
Everything.
Like one day he's going to drop it.
I um,
I kind of dropped it a little.
The amazing atheist,
right?
Yeah.
I mean I still,
I still use it.
I oscillate.
I'm kind of trying to transition to just
using my real name.
Well,
the last time you were here you talked
about that and that was I think two
years ago.
So this was a low,
it was a year and three months ago.
Oh,
that's it.
Yeah.
Really?
Wow.
It was January of 2016.
Why do I feel like it was so my memory,
I don't know.
You know what,
that Dunbar's number thing where you can
only fit so many people in your brain.
Yeah.
And there's a,
there's definitely that going on in my
head and then too much data.
My hard drive is fucked.
You know,
have to get an old laptop and he keeps
telling you you'd have to delete some
files because you're running out of
space.
And that's my brain.
Yeah.
I mean my brain is even worse because
literally things like things I knew
yesterday,
I don't know today anymore.
Yeah.
Like my memory is dog shit.
And you were just saying you haven't
smoked pot days.
Yup.
Hmm.
Not In days.
Interesting.
Days and days,
days and days and days I fucked up with,
had an edible last night I did this a,
this is a show that my friend Jeremiah
Watkins House and it's um,
like a make 'em up show or they call it
stand up on the spot where the audience
would yell out,
you know,
uh,
Fried Broccoli,
like whatever.
And you just have to rant on Broccoli,
like what,
what your thoughts are,
try to get some comedy out of it.
And occasionally maybe one out of 10
subjects,
it will actually yield a real bit.
That'll come become a bit in your act.
It's really kind of amazing because when
you put on the pressure like that,
so I said,
what a good time to test the deep end of
the pool and uh,
find out what these a speed we'd edibles
are all about.
Oh,
I fucked up.
Yeah.
Fucked up.
My,
uh,
my brother had a like a panic attack on
a edibles just like a few days ago.
Uh,
my friend brought over some like pot
brownies and um,
he had one,
he's not really used to edibles.
Anyway,
I go to bed,
I'm laying down and watching like star
Trek,
deep space nine or some shit.
I got a knock on the door like,
Tj,
Hey Max,
you come out here for a minute.
I'm like,
okay,
what the hell is this?
I got there.
It's like,
I feel like a man had a heart attack
dude.
I'm like,
dude,
you probably just having a panic attack
from too much weed.
Okay.
Has this ever happened to you?
Is this we're having to you?
I'm like,
yeah,
it's happened to me before.
Just calm down.
I know your heart's,
you feel disoriented and shit.
And,
uh,
I thought it was calming him down.
I've spent like 30 minutes talking him
down,
but fine.
You know,
and he seemed like he was like,
okay,
yeah,
I'm cool now.
And then just all the sudden like,
no,
I feel terrible.
We gotta go to the hospital.
I got to go the hospital,
I got to go to the fucking hospital.
And um,
I drove him over there and uh,
I,
I sat down in that fucking hospital
waiting room and they,
there was like this fucking ad for
Stanley steamer and there was this
terrible jingle and I'm like,
it's like the worst jingle I've ever
heard.
It's not going to get stuck in my head.
And now to this day,
call one 800 steam Stanley steamer years
certified cleaner,
I'll be in bed at night and that should
all be in my head.
Just over and over and over and over and
over again.
They have wizards would come up with
those things,
man.
Even the ones that suck,
they just get in there,
you know?
Oh yeah,
it's a terrible one.
And he gets out.
They gave him some fucking,
um,
Adavan,
you know,
you can give them next time.
Just give him some coffee.
Coffee is like one of the best things.
Really.
Yeah.
There's something about caffeine
apparently that counteracts the effects
of marijuana when you're a really high,
they said just drink some coffee.
I'll have to do that next time.
Yeah.
If that happens.
Isn't that true?
That is true.
Right?
At an a hot shower.
That's right.
Everyone's got their own fucking home
remedy for this shit I guess.
But here's the thing,
once you've done it a few times,
you realize,
well what the panic attack is,
is essentially your brain taking an
audit of all the things that are real
and a real worries that you haven't been
considering at home.
And then they fly,
well,
you're going to die someday.
Are you prepared?
Like what if it's tomorrow?
Are you ready?
Have you had a good life?
Oh,
what if someone close to you dies?
You think you're gonna be able to
recover.
Ah,
you just start thinking like really
crazy shit.
And it just makes you aware of those
things.
And then once it wears off,
you know,
you reach that sort of a neutral point
again.
Well he's a hypochondriac to begin with
so that's not good.
You can't keep guys like that weed.
You should know better.
Well he's fine if he smokes it,
but if he eats it it's different things,
different,
different shit.
Totally different thing.
So um,
your podcast,
yeah.
Was the big podcast that kind of Sunk
Milo.
It's kind of a combination of Mama need
yours.
And I remember it was years,
it was me watching him on your show that
led us to ask about that cause I saw him
on your show and he was like God at the
time.
Cause I remember at the time he was on
our show,
uh,
I told Paul,
one of my cohosts like Paul,
this guy ain't no lightweight and he's
got a huge army of sycophants right now.
If you get into debate with him,
if you lose,
you're a total bitch.
If you tie,
you lose.
If you win by a little,
The only way you can actually beat him
with his army of sycophants at this time
is if you just demolish him.
So don't even try.
You were concerned about this,
like this is like something you planned
out in advance.
No,
I mean I wasn't really,
it wasn't really a plan.
I just wanted to bring it up cause I saw
him on your show sane and I'm like,
that's very strange.
I kind of knew where he was coming from.
Sure.
Cause I knew that he had had
experiences,
like sexual experiences when he was
younger and he was kind of,
I think he was trying to trivialize them
and turn them into humor.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
I mean his way of dealing with it or
whatever,
um,
you know,
say I owe me and it was mutual between
me and the priest.
I was molested by a priest,
but I was in new it,
so it was cool.
He was like,
I was the predator.
Yeah.
Like,
like he said,
Deuce the priest,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
it's kind of hard for me to imagine a 13
year old boy,
no matter how flamboyantly gay or
sexually aggressive,
uh,
you know,
jumping the priest bones or something,
you know.
Well,
I think it,
it sort of gives you a better
understanding of how this guy came to
be,
who he is today and why he's so relishes
this role of being the contrarian and
being this,
uh,
this sort of very difficult to
pigeonhole gay man who's very
conservative but yet believes in man.
Boy Love.
This is a,
if you go back and you read old articles
that he wrote for publications that he
worked for in the past,
um,
there was a lot of stuff like we're
going to take on bullying on twitter and
you know,
we need to make a safe space for people.
Um,
online.
This is Milo and now,
yeah,
he's like the biggest troll.
Right?
Uh,
I mean we talked about my low last time.
I was on your show and you told me you
kind of put the seed in my brain,
like [inaudible] kind of like fake.
And the more I've looked into it,
the more I have to question whether or
not that shit with the priest even
happened to begin with.
Yeah.
Cause I just don't,
I don't know.
I don't really trust the shit that comes
out of his mouth in terms of like face
value.
Right.
And I think a lot of times when Milo
tries to make a point,
um,
he doesn't necessarily make it by
directly saying it.
He tries to make it through uh,
like performance art.
Like when he went on Bill Maher and,
um,
and you know,
he's,
he's doing this whole flamboyant gay
conservative thing because he wants the,
the Liberal Bill Maher audience to be
like boom,
boom.
Cause it's like,
oh look what hypocrites.
They say they accept gays,
but the second you don't tow their line,
what they obviously like is people who
told their line,
not gay people.
Uh,
I think that was the point he was trying
to make.
I thought it was funny too,
how Bill Maher the next day after,
um,
Milo scandal broke was like I took him
down.
It was me.
It was his hand.
Yeah.
It's like I took,
I took them down.
It's like,
dude,
you compare it.
You said he was the next hitchens when
he was on your shit.
Wait a minute.
He really said he tells him down and
said,
I took him down.
No,
choke him down.
Oh,
he's a fool.
That's such a foolish thing to think.
I don't,
I,
you know what I think is what Milo does,
a lot of it is performance art.
Yeah.
It's a lot of trolling and it's a lot of
very calculated stuff designed to sort
of rile people up and get people active
and get people to talk about him.
I mean that's the reason why he does
this tour on colleges.
I mean,
why wilds?
Why not do it in the lion's den if you
want to get the roars?
I mean he's doing it like where he feels
like this problem is the greatest.
Oh,
he wants to stir that pot too because he
knows if he just does it in some club
downtown.
Yeah.
And it's,
there's not going to be any protest and
was going to give a shit.
It's still protest,
I'm sure.
But not like bringing it to their camp.
They won't be like what happened at
Berkeley?
Yes.
Yeah.
What happened at Berkeley?
It was just fucking insane.
It's really insane.
Is that,
was it the mayor of San Francisco that
was applauding the protests like,
hey,
fuck face.
There was $100,000 worth of property
damage.
People throwing chairs through starbucks
windows and light and cop cars on fire.
If this,
this ain't good.
There's been articles on like the
Huffington,
I almost made a video about this article
on the Huffington post actually,
that was basically like,
um,
violence is as valid a reaction to trump
as anything.
And it's like,
wow,
you're literally just advocating for
violence.
Uh,
and you think you're so enlightened.
Yeah.
It's completely foolish.
It's like,
it goes in once.
Things aren't going their way.
It goes against everything they've stood
before.
Before.
What about kindness?
What about compassion?
What about treating people with love?
What about facts?
Well,
that's okay.
When they're in power.
Exactly.
That's okay when they're in power,
but when someone else's in that they
don't like it all kind of goes out.
They'll kind of goes both ways though
it.
Oh yeah,
it definitely does mean,
remember when Obama was in office and
there was people that were calling him a
Muslim and they were talking about
taking them out.
I ain't fucking,
I remember,
uh,
I heard rednecks.
I was living in Louisiana at the time he
was elected and I heard redneck say shit
like,
man,
I can't wait for someone who was Sasha,
nate,
this piece of shit,
you know,
there's like,
they were looking forward to it.
Like not only did they think it was
inevitable he'd be assassinated,
but it was like,
yeah,
that's going to be a good thing.
That's going to be a good day for
America when Obama was finally killed.
And when they say things like that and
you corner them,
you go,
okay,
well what,
what's so bad about them?
What Bob would drives you?
So nuts.
He's a Kenyan,
he's a Muslim and he says Shosha list.
Yes.
Socialists,
socialist months.
Muslim Kenyon,
communist,
a secret Muslim.
I would love it if someone pulled off
socialism somewhere.
Like if there was one country can go,
well,
look,
those guys are happy.
I mean those folks,
if you look at socialism as like a
gradient,
then there's plenty of countries that
are,
that have like more or less they're
socialists.
Pure socialism is a good idea anymore
than like pure capitalism.
Like,
oh,
we just need laissez faire.
Liberty.
Like the the the libertarian idea.
Like yeah,
the markets will take care of
everything.
How many libertarians is it take to
screw in a light bulb?
None.
The free market will take care of it.
Yeah,
well those people get a little goofy and
you know,
the the most frustrating to me is the
anarchists.
The ones who walk on,
no taxes.
No,
no cops.
No.
Nobody fixes the roads and private
police.
All those.
Even wars.
Yeah.
It's like private police.
Like how does that work?
You mean everyone,
if you're,
if you have money,
you just hire out your own justice.
I mean higher up thugs d does that
really seem like they would be objective
and in pursuit of like a justice?
It seems like they would just be your
armed thugs that are going to meet out
whatever form of justice you think is
appropriate.
Yeah,
well for sure.
If they're working for you,
that'd be an issue.
If you're the big boss and the big boss
wants these laws and forest,
you know,
and then the big boss passes zone laws
on his property,
it makes things different.
It's like it gets real weird when you're
dealing with 350 million people.
That's really a part of the problem.
It's what,
what the style of civilization that
works well for one person is not what's
preferred by another person and all
those things combined with the,
the whole an antiquated voting system,
the whole ridiculous electoral college
system.
He just said,
we're never going to achieve some sort
of peace of mind.
Super Delegates and Democratic Party.
Those are the most ridiculous.
Wait,
wait a minute.
Hold on you a super delicate so you can,
how does that work?
You can decide not to vote for the way
the entire state voted.
Yes,
that's right.
Unbelievable.
And leaving it up to them to make sure
that trump doesn't get a stop gap.
You know,
like because the,
the people in power have always been
afraid of the actual will of the people.
So anything they can do,
they want to safeguard like,
well if the people choose poorly,
you know,
we want to be able to stop that from
happening.
Yeah,
we have to those uninformed fools.
We can't leave them up to their own
decision.
In all fairness,
I've been around America and there are a
lot of uninformed fools.
There's a few,
quite a few.
What do you think you think it's like
half of us are uninformed fools.
I wouldn't even want to throw out a
number,
but there's just a lot of people that
are stupid.
I mean it's hard to know because you
know,
you really almost don't know what
someone really thinks until you sit down
with them one by one,
you know,
one on one and have a conversation.
And even then,
well you don't keep a real job.
Right.
When was the last time you had a real
job?
A job job.
I worked at,
I hop for two days.
About 10 years ago.
That's it.
More than 10 years ago.
And what have you been doing for the
most part since then?
Youtube.
Yeah.
See if you can make it live and doing
something else.
In this day and age you're,
you're,
you're removed from the grid.
And if you,
if your mood from the employer,
employee grid,
you get to see things in a different
way.
You Go,
well this is all temporary and you know,
everyone's working towards some future
that really never comes.
You're,
this is like the life that you're
experiencing right now is life.
Yeah.
And most people are spending that time
doing shit they don't want to do and it
fills up all their time.
So then when it comes to government and
it comes to like who's leading the
country,
which directions the country going into,
how much time to be
actually spend paying attention to it
and actually spend really considering
it.
I mean,
I've had a,
I've been at people's houses where I'll
try to bring up,
um,
Paul news or politics or something like
that.
They get sick and people are just like,
we don't talk about that in this
household.
Whoo.
It's like Wiley.
You don't want it.
I mean,
like,
even like,
not even necessarily politics,
but just news like,
yeah.
Did you hear about this thing that
happened?
I don't like news.
It depresses me.
Is this a woman?
Is this also like a woman's voice?
Yeah,
that was the woman.
And this is a,
this is the,
it was a woman voice.
Not In my house.
Woman,
not in my house.
We don't,
we don't put up with that shit around
here.
We have ways that we allow you to
communicate inside these borders.
By the way,
I did lose my,
I hop job by dumping pancakes on
somebody.
You did?
Yeah.
Who Was it?
This fat fuck.
You know what?
But I went into the job and,
uh,
and I was like,
all right,
look,
I,
I'm not good with people.
Don't put me anywhere near front of
House.
I'm being the kitchen.
I'm going to do.
I was living in Alabama at the time.
I was like,
uh,
18 I had a 32 year old girlfriend.
Oh Shit.
So I was like,
you know,
you're mature.
Yeah.
And um,
and she's like,
you know,
I was laying around the house every day
while she went and worked and eventually
she's like,
you need to get a job.
And I'm like,
all right,
reasonable.
I guess.
Hey,
you're banging a 32 year old.
It should have been psyched.
Yeah.
Oh,
well,
I was at first,
but then when she said,
get a job,
I was like,
yeah,
but I did.
I'm like,
all right,
I'm going to try to make this work.
So I went to,
I hop and they were like,
yeah,
you just work the back.
I'm like,
okay,
cool.
I'll work the back.
I'll just,
I'll do dishes.
I'll just turn my brain off and wash the
dishes and you know,
I'll,
I'll learn to do the grill or whatever
the fuck else.
A second day I was there,
they're like,
we're short staffed.
We're gonna need you to just take care
of a few tables.
I'm like,
it's not a good idea.
I'm not,
I'm not good with the public training.
We've had to do it.
When they say short stuff now sent you
out there,
they're just like,
yeah.
And I mean they get,
they told me like,
yeah,
you just,
you know,
hang out down there orders.
Yeah.
Just go out,
write out,
you know,
we know you're not going to be great at
it,
whatever,
but go do it.
We're short staff.
We need you.
Everyone else in the kitchen is more
vital than you are because they've all
been here a long time.
So,
uh,
I went out and I took,
I waited on unlike three or four tables
and then there was this one fat fuck who
maybe like,
I mean it,
it had been awhile.
This bliss place was not well run.
The fact that they sent me out to
fucking wait tables is evidence of that.
So it was like 15 minutes and he hadn't
got his fucking,
uh,
pancakes and breakfast and shit.
And he's like,
where my pancakes?
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm,
I'll go check you better.
You better,
you better.
That just rang in my head,
you know,
like the same as that jingle.
You better,
you better,
you better.
It's like I don't recall you sign in my
fucking paychecks.
Uh,
so I just went up to him with a pancake
train.
I just dumped it in his lap and like,
there you go bitch.
Wow.
I walked out.
That's all it took was you been,
you know what,
I fucking,
I was,
I was out there in the parking lot for
about seven hours because I didn't have
a cell phone.
Uh,
I didn't have a ride.
It wasn't seven hours and we're like
four or five,
but I was just wandering around in a
parking lot.
I couldn't even stay in the IHOC parking
lot cause I didn't want anyone from
there to come in.
But I just wondered around the parking
lot at the shopping center for four
hours waiting for my girlfriend to show
up when she finally did,
I was just like,
yeah,
I quit.
Didn't tell her the story.
Just told her I quit.
And uh,
we broke up shortly after that I would
imagine that wouldn't work out.
It didn't work out well.
You were 18.
Yeah,
I was young,
so I was young and stupid.
You were young.
Now I'm a little stupid.
You were antisocial,
slightly forced into a situation that
you didn't desire.
I'm extremely antisocial in general.
Are you?
Yeah,
still to this day.
But that's interesting because you do
youtube videos and you talk and you talk
with people on a podcast,
which is pretty social.
Yeah.
I'm getting better at it,
but I'm,
you know,
I'm still,
I'm still not comfortable around
strangers and shit.
Yeah.
You get uncomfortable when you do
podcasts like this one.
Does this make you and go,
oh yeah.
You know,
like a lot of people,
um,
when,
when I guess they figured out I was
coming on here again,
I read a threat on,
uh,
the,
the drunken peasants,
a subreddit where people were talking
about,
yeah.
You know,
he's gonna be on Joe Rogan again and
then,
you know,
people are like,
yeah,
I liked last time,
but I hope he's not so nervous this
time.
Oh,
we can't say that because he's like,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Well,
I,
I was nervous last time,
like last time I did your show,
I came in here and I talked to you and
then I left and I was like,
I have no idea what the content of the
conversation I just had was when I got
here.
I don't remember fucking word.
You were already baked out of your mind
when I got here.
That's true too.
That was,
I don't remember much of what we talked
about either,
but it was good.
That's why you're back.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I enjoyed it.
I've never been able to watch it though.
Yeah.
I don't watch them.
I can't watch it at all.
I mean,
usually I will watch everything that I'm
in and just am in love with the sound of
my own voice and obsessive and you know,
all that shit.
But,
uh,
like this,
this shall,
I couldn't watch it just because I can't
stand like I can't watch my CNN
appearance either.
What'd you do CNN about?
Uh,
I went on CNN because they were doing,
there was like a new poll out that
showed that the faith was on the decline
in America.
So they had me on there,
but unfortunately I was supposed to be
on 30 minutes,
but unfortunately that was the day that
fucking,
uh,
ratzinger resigned.
Uh,
so that it got preempted for that shit.
But I was on for about four minutes and
I,
I had like an argument with a William
Lane Craig about statistics and you
know,
William Lane Craig,
he's a Christian apologist piece of
shit.
He's horrible.
He's just wretched.
You can watch him debate,
uh,
hitchins and I think now he never
debated duck and speak and watch them
debate hitchens.
Terrible stuff.
Yeah,
that sounds like not,
not so good.
Just the name William Lane Craig.
It's like settle down buddy here.
Yeah.
Why not just William Craig?
Why you got through that lane in there?
Unless you're married to someone whose
last name is lane and that's always a
disaster.
A hyphenated marriages.
That shit just seems like someone's like
the,
that is an oil wrestling match.
Someone's going to lose.
You guys are going to lose.
It's not going to work.
It's too much.
Too much struggle for power there.
That's true.
Hyphenated name plus.
What do you do if you have what I mean
it?
Yeah.
Well what happens when it compounds,
you know like the kids are born.
Do they take the hyphenated name?
Exactly.
And then what if they meet and fall in
love with someone else who has a
hyphenated name?
Do they then have like four last names
with 300 kids in it?
You know,
it's like so is it just compound over
time like until eventually everyone has
every single last name.
Just hyphenated.
That's true.
If everybody was so greedy and wanted to
be special the way those assholes do,
we would all have hyphenated names.
Yeah,
it'd be a real problem.
Maybe just get rid of the fucking name,
change shit and just argue about what
the kids are going to be named.
I don't want to,
how do you feel about people changing
their names?
Like what if you just decided like I
want to change my whole name.
I'm based in last,
might want to become a new person.
My Dad changed his name.
Did he?
Yeah,
it did have a crazy last name.
Hard to pronounce.
No,
it wasn't that my grandfather,
look,
I'm Thomas James Kirk the third,
but I'm the first person in my family to
have that name.
So what?
Yeah,
what happened was my grandfather was
named James Vardaman,
Kirk James Kirk.
So when my dad was James Vardaman,
Kurt junior star trek came out at some
point and he's James Kirk.
So he's getting star trek jokes nonstop
all the time.
Finally he was in France and uh,
he ordered up some champagne.
It was Rome.
He's impressing a young woman and
they're like,
oh it,
we'll beam,
it's right up sir.
And he's like,
fuck this name.
I got to get rid of this.
So when I was born,
uh,
Thomas James Kirk the third,
because he knew he was changing his name
to Thomas James Kirk Junior,
but he didn't actually officially change
it till after I was born.
So even though I'm the third,
I'm actually the first.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
No one would ever guess that an
attribute test.
Nope.
He would sneak that one right through.
That's annoying.
That's like there's no one probably
today that's named Rick James.
Like anyone born after the Chappelle
show,
there's no fucking way anyone who saw
the Chappelle show was named their kid,
Rick James.
If you're,
if your last name's James,
you're not going to name your boy rick.
Right.
I mean,
I don't know.
Maybe some people are like,
damn right,
Rick James Bitch James Bitch.
That was a real problem with Chappelle's
career.
Um,
that Rick James Bitch thing.
People yell it out at shows.
Just constantly yell it out.
Like White Bros,
like,
you know the,
you know,
the,
the guy who would yell at,
you could see him,
you know,
I'm Rick James Bitch.
Like drunk Rick James Bitch.
Woo.
Yeah.
And he'd just,
people apparently just kept doing that.
It shows it was like a real problem for
awhile.
You should've done like,
uh,
just be like Schwartzenegger just
embrace it.
Yeah.
Schwartz in here,
it goes around.
He always is using all,
you were terminated and all this shit.
You know,
he just embraces it because he knows
people just fucking get that shit in
their head and they want to hear it.
So he's like,
fuck it.
Give it to him.
Yeah,
he did it on the new apprentice.
Right?
Dominate.
Yeah.
I never saw it.
Did you see it?
No.
No I didn't.
I didn't even watch the old one.
But he'll fucking go around like he'll,
he'll do all of this little lines.
I'll be back and all this shit.
You know he doesn't care.
No,
he doesn't.
That's just a trademark.
That's his shit.
I got scared of it.
I love the fucking,
there was a rally where someone threw
eggs at Arnold Schwartzenegger.
They threw eggs.
I don't know how they threw eggs and got
on his suit and he's like,
well that's what's great about America,
but they owe me some bacon.
You know?
It's like,
what?
You're so fucking smooth,
Arnold.
You should be president.
Threw eggs at them.
Yeah.
What kind people just looking for a
reason to get mad.
I'm pissed because Arnold,
he's the problem in America.
Arnold fucking Schwartzenegger was he a
good governor now?
Was he a bad governor?
No,
not really.
It was just half assed,
half assed,
mediocre.
Governor,
do you think it's almost impossible to
jump in later in life without going
through the river of politics first?
Well,
house of cards style,
I'm just kind of done it.
You're right.
But housing,
I mean he's in,
but I mean is it going to work?
You know what I mean?
Like Arnold Schwarzenegger got into like
in the relationship to the same,
you know,
the same sort of situation.
I mean,
does it really,
it works enough to where he's president.
It's true.
I mean,
yeah,
it worked that well.
I mean,
his approval ratings are kind of dog
shit,
but they always were.
But like when you say whether or not
Arnold Schwarzenegger was a good,
good governor,
I don't know.
I don't really know enough about it.
I would have to like really look into
it.
But yeah,
I mean,
uh,
the,
the big thing was that,
uh,
he,
he tried to pass all these,
um,
I guess the laws is not really the word
I'm looking for,
but I'll use that.
He tried to pass all these like laws and
uh,
they all failed at the ballot and um,
people said he was done and he would
just went out and like he went out and
made a speech that almost gave you the
impression like he'd been against them
from the start.
Like yes,
these terrible laws,
they are gone.
It's like,
okay,
you're the one who pushed them,
but whatever.
He was really smooth that just,
uh,
operating with crowds and just knew what
to say,
new,
the right attitude to strike.
But in terms of actually governing,
it was just mediocre.
He didn't really get much done
legislatively,
but he didn't really,
he wasn't really a disaster either.
Yeah.
Well that's what I was thinking like,
oh,
wonder how difficult it is to get things
done.
Like we'd only be guessing like sitting
here on the outside and that guy that
you were talking to,
like Obama was a piece of shit like that
kind of a guy.
Yeah.
Like how much of it,
how much of it do you think he really
grasps?
Very little.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody who's not doing it
grasps how complex that system,
you know,
you and I probably both know that the
more people you involve in any sort of
endeavor or project,
the more difficult it becomes because
you're managing all these different
interests for sure.
So when you're,
you know,
president or governor or something like
that,
you have so many people that you're
supposed to be representing and they all
have different ideas and there they all
have their own,
uh,
there's other legislators who have their
agendas and shit.
So it's probably pretty difficult to get
much of anything done.
Could you imagine the stress of that
job?
I mean,
just a mansion.
That's why,
uh,
trump's been golfing so many times just
to try to relieve stress.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
I mean like he,
he criticized Obama for golfing too much
and now trump's like a big avid golfer.
I can't even imagine it.
I mean,
the guy's 70 years old to like,
why would even want to take this on with
all that money and all that,
you know,
all that power already.
Like,
why would he,
why would he want to be the president?
It just seems like such a fucking
helacious job.
Unless he really feels like he can fix
things or he's really gonna make a ton
of money from it.
I mean this is a guy who plasters is his
fucking name on,
on hildings and shit,
you know.
So I think it's really just a matter for
him of like,
this is part of my legacy.
You know,
towards the end of my life I was
president of the United States.
It's so weird.
It's so weird cause it's,
it's another version of what many people
did with Obama in this weird way in that
when Obama got into office,
there was all these like really,
really irrational people that said all
kinds of crazy shit.
And by the way,
trump was amongst them.
He was a birther.
Yeah,
he was a member for the longest time.
He was convinced.
Somebody convinced him.
I Dunno who convinced him.
I Dunno if you've really relinquished it
and realize that it was wrong or if he
still holds on to the idea.
Did he ever really believe it too?
I don't know.
You know,
But you know who started that whole
birther thing?
Hillary Clinton.
Yeah,
she did.
That's right.
That's something that people forget.
It was during the,
uh,
the campaign between her and a Obama
when they were trying to get the
nomination in 2008.
Yeah,
yeah.
She,
she had,
well she had one of her little org send
out materials that you know,
showed Obama and like the like he was
wearing like some African Muslim garb
shit.
Cause he went on a visit to some other
co.
You look at him,
you know,
he's Muslim and uh,
and trump just ran with that.
Yeah.
Or a lot of Republicans did to cause
it's,
you know,
well I guess that's just how they play
politics.
They have some like that,
they just run with it.
It's just so strange to see when you got
to Canada named Barack Obama,
I know it's easy.
Hussein,
Hussein Obama,
like Barack Hussein Obama Sane in that
to guide it,
you know,
ran a rack and Obama,
it had the similar to the name of the
guy that crashed those planes into the
towers.
And yeah,
somebody had a joe really good,
well wrote a joke.
I don't remember who it was though.
It might have been Tony Hinchcliffe but
the,
I mean it's just,
this is almost a s a similar reaction.
I don't mean it's less,
it's more rational or less rational.
What I mean is almost like the energy of
the reaction,
like the energy of the birthers and the
guys who were convinced that he was some
sort of undercover Muslim and then he
was going to get into the White House
and try to take America down from the
inside.
Like that feeling,
that the amount of energy that way his
mirror now on the left maybe even
though,
yeah,
maybe even past,
I would say probably I might not be
right because I might not be remembering
it perfectly,
but I feel like the energy on the left
of people getting mad at trump is more
powerful or more,
there's more to it than the energy that
I saw from people on the right.
They wanted Obama out of office,
but it might just be my memory.
And you gotta remember too,
there's an age gap there.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
most of the people who were talking this
shit about Obama were,
were pretty old.
Right.
And a lot of the people now that are
pissed or really young,
so they're more likely to take to the
streets and smash things and hold up
signs and,
you know,
act wild and shit and mace people.
Yeah.
You know,
when Bush took office though,
like when Bush,
uh,
was,
was being inaugurated,
I remember that he was driving down,
uh,
to the,
to the White House during the
inauguration day.
And they were,
you know,
with,
with trump,
the protesters kinda came the next day.
But with,
when Bush was inaugurated,
the protesters were all there the day
of.
And you know,
Bush couldn't even do the little
traditional walk down the last few
blocks of the,
the journey because there was so many
protestors and people were just throwing
things at the fucking motorcade and
shit.
So I mean like this is not unusual,
but that was towards the end.
Now that was the very beginning.
What am I,
which 1:00 AM I thinking of?
Wasn't there one towards the very end?
The W
I think we're thinking of different
ones.
Okay.
I think I'm,
my memory's fucked up,
but I think there was one towards the
end where they had planned on having him
walk down some long stretch and they had
to abandon it and get them into a car.
Is that the same stores?
Uh,
yeah.
Well I think that was both times.
I think it was the first,
but even during his first,
uh,
time,
like when he was just first being
inaugurated president in 2000 so right
after Clinton that inauguration was bad.
It was almost the same.
Yeah,
it was terrible.
It was almost the same as what you see
now because people had had this Democrat
in power for eight years and they
thought like,
yeah.
And they thought Gore is a shoe in
because Clinton's popular,
just same
as like Hillary's a shoe in because
Obama's popular.
Right.
But,
you know,
a Republican ended up taking,
uh,
taking it and,
and they just freaked out.
And it seems like that always just
happens.
I mean,
like this kind of like backlash.
Like it always is kind of sold to us as
like,
this is new,
this is like,
Oh wow,
look at what's going on now.
Isn't this crazy what crazy times we
live in?
But it's,
I look back at my memories of the past
and it seems like this is pretty par for
the course.
I think you're right,
now that I'm thinking about it,
it's almost like we go through these
like cycles.
Yeah.
And if a president gets past one cycle
removed from his,
his tenure,
then people forgive them.
They forget and they changed their
opinion.
Yeah.
Like Reagan,
like man,
when I was a kid,
Reagan was a pariah.
Like people were so upset about Reagan,
they were so upset.
And there was the contra versus
Nicaragua,
a trial that was on television with
Oliver North and we were finding out on
tv like whether or not the government
had sold arms and lied about it and
weather.
And then,
you know,
the,
the whole Reagan thing with winning that
Reagan sold arms to Iran,
the great Jimmy Tangle,
hilarious standup comedian and Boston
has this bit about it because they were,
that was when Reagan started claiming
all timers or when he claimed memory
issues,
which turned out to be true.
I mean,
you really did have memory issues and he
probably did it at a time,
but they asked him,
did you sell arms to Iraq?
He said,
I don't know.
And Timmy tangles,
like mister president,
if you ever sell arms to people who hate
us,
jot it down.
I was like,
make a note,
put it on the refrigerator today.
I sold Amz to people who hate me.
You have to hear him say,
I mean,
you know it.
You have to realize that like America's
always has been a huge arms dealer.
I mean,
we're constantly selling weapons.
Oh yeah.
I mean like if he,
if he didn't remember why he did it,
it's probably because there were just so
many other transactions.
I don't think the president personally
gets involved too much in that sort of
stuff,
but probably not.
Country sells weapons all over the place
and we continue to do that.
Yeah.
My point was that like eight years later
he was the great Ronald Reagan.
Oh yeah.
Eight years later,
and eyes,
he goes through the Clinton
administration.
Everybody's done with the Clinton
getting his dick sucked and the White
House and all that craziness.
And,
and then as soon as that's over,
people start reminiscing to Reagan.
It's really interesting.
It's really interesting how we do it.
And so now Bush went through this period
of being hated and he's out of office at
Obama,
goes through his period of being hated
for eight years.
And now that,
and even more unreasonable Republicans
in office people long to the Bush days.
Oh yeah.
Like you noticed they're trotting Bush
out and doing interviews with him.
Like,
Hey,
remember this war criminal now he's
okay.
He's,
he's an uncle Bush the bush here.
Uncle Bush go set you on his knee.
They um,
super imposed.
What does that protests during the Bush
administration now figurations.
Yeah.
Yup.
Wow.
What does it say?
Fuck Bush.
Oh,
buck flush.
Flush.
There's a couple of years,
not my president of course.
Man,
of course.
So you know,
this is,
this is all so cyclic.
Yeah.
It just happens over and over again and
people think it's new and you know,
for some,
I think,
I guess it's the country just has a
short memory to what a crazy show.
This is.
What a crazy show we're watching the
battle to control the world.
Yeah.
Political Theater,
pageantry.
But you know,
like it's just,
I mean like I don't want to get into
like you already had Alex Jones on the
show,
so I can't really get into that level of
territory.
But I mean I do agree that these parties
are constantly just working together
behind the scenes and that 90% of the
issues they agree on,
they just make a big spectacle of the
little things they actually disagree on
to distract us with a show.
You Look America,
look,
look at us,
we're fighting,
we're fighting.
Have they stopped paying attention?
Okay,
now we've met,
now we do the real deals.
Who are we going to bomb?
Who we going to invade?
You know,
uh,
who were going to sell weapons to
whatever.
Yeah.
It's probably definitely some of that.
I mean,
if they're all working together,
if you watch house of cards,
do you watch house of cards?
Uh,
I watched the first season,
but when he started pushing people in
front of trains and shit,
I was like,
sh spoiler alert.
Sorry.
This is the beginning of season two.
I mean the vein,
seeing that whatever.
Listen man,
I'm only on season three.
Oh,
okay.
I just got into it.
I've been been binge watching Jeanette.
Look,
I really like Kevin Spacey's
performance,
but it just got a little over the top
for me,
you know.
All right buddy.
Well,
we all have different standards,
I guess.
Uh,
I'm sorry.
I don't,
I'm not insulting the show.
Isn't that a funny thing though?
Like if someone likes something and you
don't like it,
it gets personal sometimes.
Yeah.
Like,
especially like music.
Oh,
music.
It's like you listen to that shit.
This is really shit you listen to.
Like,
people get mad.
I can get,
I can get mad.
Like if someone's like,
you know,
I really liked beyonce or something,
I'd be like,
you'd get mad.
What if you got in the car and someone's
playing like some like Electronica,
Eh,
uh,
you know,
like a,
like a villain and some sort of a coen
brothers movie,
like Belsky Villain.
Remember those guys?
You know,
I was a,
I was in an uber the other day where
someone was playing like,
it sounded like fucking elevator music.
Like it was like he was just listening
to the shit you hear in fucking
elevators and it was like a 45 minute
drive and I'm just like,
oh my God.
I mean,
I can't say anything.
It's his fucking car.
This is drive to be fucking up the wall.
Could you bring it up to me?
A lot of it bring it up.
I mean,
I,
I'm sure I'm allowed to,
I mean there,
there's,
there's nothing's going to happen if I,
if I bring it up,
but I just don't want it.
I don't want to have that discussion
like,
Hey,
can you change your music because it's
horrible to me and it's grading on my
last nerve right now you're supposed to,
you get control of that music and the,
with the APP,
you know,
like,
I didn't mean that we bad at dealing
with people with the APP.
Yeah.
With Uber App.
There's a button it connects to your
spotify said like they're supposed to
offer the ox cord when you get in the
car so you can control the music with
double annoying for the driver I would
imagine.
But yeah,
if they're supposed to give you control,
really?
Whoa.
See I've never,
I've never taken that right.
So you let them just,
I just let them do what they do over
with the shitty music.
I mean cause I mean at the end of the
day they're the ones who have to drive
around in this fucking car all day and
I'm just getting a ride.
So I feel like an asshole being like,
no,
I'm going to pose my musical tastes on
you cause I feel like it's their car,
whatever there.
Well it's definitely their car.
It's also,
what's weird is why is music suck to us
and it's great to some people.
Like what is that?
What is it about a song that you go,
oh that's a fucking great song.
And someone else would go turn that off.
I don't know.
It's like it,
it kind of reminds me of something with
food.
Like people have different food
preferences and shit and I was wondering
like,
I'm eating a pickle and you know,
I like it.
Other people hate pickles.
So when they eat a pickle,
does it taste different to them than it
does to me?
Or is it the same taste but they just
don't like that taste?
Yeah.
And I kind of wonder the same thing
about the music thing.
Yeah,
I think for sure.
I think it's,
um,
I probably,
it's probably a visual thing too and
not,
not visual in terms of like taking
account of space and mass,
but visual and account of like what,
what each individual image does for you.
Like how it looks too.
Yeah.
I like the overall feeling it gives you,
I think it's different for everybody.
It just has to be,
it has to be,
I mean,
what would it,
what else would account for all the
different tastes?
Yeah,
the obvious different,
especially music,
but then this like tastes that you very,
yourself,
like you ever catch yourself in some
weird mix?
Like you hit ipod shuffle or something
like that and you catch some weird mix
of songs that you like and you're like,
wow,
they just do not go together.
Like these two are just really weird.
Back to back.
Yeah.
You know,
going,
going back to the food thing,
like,
you know,
there's certain foods you might like,
but maybe together they're not so great.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And then certain foods you would think
would not be good together but are
amazing like a pineapple and anchovies.
See,
uh,
I don't,
I don't like either of those by
themselves.
So dude on pizza,
the high end apple anchovy pizza.
Oh,
you're one of those pineapple on Pizza
People,
Huh?
Very rarely.
Only with anchovies.
I'm not a Hawaiian pizza guy.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't even think Hawaiians are
Hawaiian pizza people.
Who's,
who's getting that?
Hammond?
I'm a,
I'm a big,
if it's Canadian Bacon,
why is it a Hawaiian Pizza?
That's a real good question,
man.
That's a super good question.
Why is it and how the fuck is that
Bacon?
It's not,
if you go to Canada and say,
I want some bacon.
They don't bring you that shit.
Yeah,
that's some,
yeah.
What is that?
That's like a Belgium waffle.
Why is it from Belgium?
This is a god there isn't a waffle.
No,
the fucked up thing is I went to
Belgium,
then I got a waffle there and it's
nothing like what they fucking say it,
you know that we Belgian waffles here,
they're like round and you put it on a
plate with syrup.
They give you like,
it's like street food there.
You get like a little tiny fork and
there's like a small waffle,
it's not even round.
And they put whatever the fuck you want.
It's not just syrup.
They'll put like fresh strawberries and
all kinds of shit on there and you just
sit there and eat it with this little
tiny ridiculous fork.
And it's totally different than what
what's called a Belgian waffle in
America.
So it's like one of those,
um,
you ever go to one of those crepe
stands?
Yeah,
it's in the mall.
You know,
like they make you a little crepes and
waffles and stuff and they put new tell
autumn and the watch different.
I would say it's probably closer to
that.
Yeah.
That's God damn delicious.
That's way better than a Belgium waffle.
Fuck yeah.
But at Belgium [inaudible] was easy to
do,
you know,
put it in that mold.
Yeah.
Stamp that sucker down.
Paul.
Dot.
Waffle Tj and Joe Rogan talk about
waffles.
It's important to talk about Waffles,
waffle house,
one of the best road foods ever.
And uh,
cause you can guarantee you're gonna get
the same thing pretty much everywhere.
No one else,
no one else can do hash browns that I
like other than waffle house.
Sam,
good Hash browns.
They're putting crack in his fucking
Hash browns to the waffles.
Ridiculous Dude.
And you see someone,
you see so much crazy shit at waffle
houses too.
Like I was at a waffle house and uh,
the service was terrible.
I was in there for like an hour and a
half,
but God damn the show was amazing
because the cook and the one waitress
hated each other and we're fighting the
entire time.
And it got to the point where she,
she runs out,
she's in the parking lot crying and he's
like,
giving me free food,
don't report this and now you got free
food.
Oh Jesus.
It's like,
all right,
thanks.
Went to another waffle house.
And I was like,
uh,
not really a kid but like,
you know,
a teenager,
the guy that ran that waffle house was a
fucking psycho,
the cook,
he would just yell at you.
He came over to my table one time and
he's like,
this waitress is uh,
getting off soon.
I think you guys need to go pay your
bill and go,
whoa.
I'm like,
okay.
I mean this is open 24 hours.
Right?
Like what?
He's like,
no,
close it out cause she's got to go,
I guess she wants the tip before she
leaves or whatever.
Um,
so that was weird.
One time a drunk came in there holding
the like a bottle of wine or something
and he,
and he was just like,
no,
get that Outta here.
That's not allowed in here.
Get Out.
Whoa.
Just like very intense all the time.
I think it was like a retired cop or
something that was just didn't,
I don't know,
didn't get his pension or some shit.
So he's at a waffle house,
then his pension on the waffle house to
make it big.
I mean,
I don't think he wasn't the owner.
He's just a fucking cook.
Oh,
just a cook who's like cantankerous and
angry and would yell at you and attack
you.
Weird food places,
men like weird food places you traveling
and you for a brief period of time,
enter
into these people's worlds and watch
them interact with iron skillet.
I went to,
um,
this Montana diner,
this really small diner outside of
billings,
Montana with a few of my friends.
And uh,
we uh,
we pulled into this diner and we had
just got done hunting for five days in
the,
in the mountain.
So we're just,
we were dirty and it was,
it was like we were tired.
We just been camping this whole time.
We just got off of a boat and this guy
had a,
like a big piece of cardboard,
like four by four,
like four feet by four feet,
cardboard with photos of all these
different marines that he had propped up
on like an easel board and on it had all
the different soldiers that had died
under Obama's watch and this one
particular mission.
And he kept pointed out like,
these are,
these are 11 of our boys that died
because of this president,
so-called president that was not my
price and it not my brethren,
you know,
it got to that weird shit.
And he was coming over to the table and
talking to us while like,
while we were there eating.
I'm never forget that guy.
It was just so bizarre.
Like he had to go.
Yep.
It's terrible.
Yup.
It was terrible.
Can we leave?
Like we're stuck while this guy like
hovered over us with his,
his lecture is powerpoint presentation.
I mean,
he had like photos of these guys up on
this thing and he wanted to talk to
everybody about it.
Yeah.
He,
yeah.
I had a weird food experience in,
uh,
Colorado because driving,
I drove all the way from Columbus to
Seattle when I was moving because we
had,
um,
like dogs and lizards and all kinds of
shit.
So we just decided to drive it and,
uh,
you know,
to make kind of a road trip of it.
We stopped off in Colorado for like a
couple days to check that out cause I'd
never been there.
We're at the hotel restaurant.
The waiter we had was fucking like the
most bipolar fucking dude in history
because we ordered this,
you know,
uh,
fruit and meat,
cheese tray or whatever,
meat and cheese and you know,
some other shit and there's some nuts on
it.
And,
um,
somehow it comes up.
My girlfriend has like nut allergies.
Oh No.
And you know,
they're not severe.
They're really mild and she just avoids
it by not eating those nuts.
You know,
if something touches them,
they're fine.
But this guy,
he's over there like,
why didn't you tell me she had a nut
allergy?
And we're just kind of like,
ah,
this is not just not a joke.
This is a serious matter.
Don't laugh.
We take this very seriously here.
I'm not exaggerating this fucking guy
either.
Like this is like,
he's like a costing us about this shit
and he's like,
I don't even know if I should bring that
out.
out now.
And we're like,
just,
just bring it out.
She just won't eat the nuts.
And you're just like,
she can not have anything from the tray.
You understand?
Oh,
nothing from the tray.
Can She,
and were like,
and he kept asking like,
is it airborne?
Is the nut allergy airborne?
Some people have an airborne nut out.
Sure.
But she doesn't,
and she told him that and he's
persistent and he wouldn't,
he'd like ask it but not wait for the
answer.
And then he'd come back and he'd be
totally pleasant.
Like,
so you guys on the Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And then he'd leave any,
come back again and he'd be crazy again.
Like she,
she held up her glass.
He's,
he's like refilling and her glass kind
of far away.
So she like,
you know,
holds it out.
And he's like,
put that back on the table,
put that back on the table.
It's like,
what?
Whoa,
you're a fucking psycho.
That whole city though was high strung
shit.
Cause I remember I went to a pot shop
there and the guy at the pot shop,
he was like,
first of all you had,
I had to go to a waiting room,
which is just weird and like take a
number.
And then I was called into another room
when I thought it was gonna be able to
buy weed,
but instead it was just another waiting
room.
And then I finally get to the fucking
little broom closet where they keep
their meager supply a fucking weed and
there's this guy behind the counter and
he know shit was like,
what?
I'm like,
okay,
please watch.
And then we had four people with us.
He proceeds to do it to everybody.
So four times in a row,
Yay.
I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like I smoke weed to like chill out and
relax and shit,
but you're just like,
okay,
okay.
And he's,
he's bitching about how hard his job is
there too.
It's like,
man,
I can't wait till we get off works that
we could get really high.
I mean we're already high but we're
going keep it real.
That guy gets a vote to and then there
was a,
when I was leaving that fucking place,
there was like a syringe like on the
floor of the fucking weed shop.
I'm like this fucking,
it was Colorado.
We'd shit as a joke.
I think it's way better in Washington.
You just go into a fucking store like
any other store and buy it.
Well,
I think what they're worried about more
than anything is people robbing them.
Maybe that's probably why they make you
go through steps.
Like step one and step two.
Yeah,
phased introduction.
Yeah.
I mean also they can isolate you from
the outside if you have,
if they have cameras,
the cameras are monitoring you.
It's probably makes people less likely
to try to attempt an armed robbery.
Who knows?
But you could arm robbed any fucking
place I made.
Sure.
No,
it's not like it was exclusive to weed
shop for sure.
It's just a scary thing what they're
doing where they're not allowing them to
use credit cards so that they have the
keep large chunks cash around and I
think they're trying to resolve that.
I don't know if they have yet,
but it was a giant issue for a long time
because they would have to hire these
like,
uh,
like mercenaries essentially.
Yeah.
You know,
guys who worked for like black water and
stuff like that to the,
those kind of guys to carry the money
around or to guard the people that are
carrying the money around.
Did you hear
a jeff sessions recently saying that
marijuana is a dis,
like it's,
it's just a destructive fucking drug
that is almost as bad as heroin?
Yeah.
He said that to,
was it today or yesterday?
I think it was either today or yesterday
that he said,
I saw it.
It's hilarious that this guy is in
charge of anything.
Only slightly less awful.
Was his words only slightly less off of
the heroin.
Someone is without a doubt,
if that's what he's expressing,
someones without a doubt influencing
that.
Like there's,
there's more than just his opinion here.
This is not these,
when these,
they have these meetings when they're
discussing policy or the discussing how
they proceed.
Like this isn't as simple as this one
wacky dude's opinion and they leave him
alone with his opinion.
He has ultimate power.
There's no way.
There's a bunch of vested interests.
There's a bunch of people that have
tremendous amount of money at stake and
would lose money if marijuana was legal.
That is 100% why that guy was doing it.
Sure.
But I mean,
he's,
his personal opinion towards weed has
always been mean.
Like he was at lie like that.
Like that's just a fucking lie.
You don't have any data to show that
that's even remotely true.
Heroin kills fuck loads of people.
People,
their bodies are ravaged by it.
Pot doesn't do a goddamn thing to you.
It might make you a little loony.
Yeah.
Just,
I mean like,
you know,
it's not even comparable.
No.
And if you might be schizophrenia exams
where they looked at all the,
the population and they said,
you know,
marijuana contributes to schizophrenia.
And they were like,
well,
no,
actually no.
If you look at the number,
it's always 1% and it feels 1% of
smoking pot or not smoking pot.
It's still,
the schizophrenia numbers have always
been around 1%.
Yeah.
I mean like it can be exacerbated by
marijuana,
I'm sure.
But it's not,
it doesn't cause it.
Yeah.
I think,
I don't,
I'm not a brain scientist,
nor are you,
are you?
You're not.
I had,
I've,
I've dealt with schizophrenia.
People,
you know them,
right?
Yeah.
I've known a few.
It's,
um,
I think it probably varies like any
other kind of mental illness.
But what pisses me off though more than
even like the personal angle of like,
I'm a pot smoker and this affects me
personally.
I mean,
that does get my goat a little bit,
but what really pisses me off is that
trump is mr jobs.
Yeah.
This industry,
this $7 billion recreational marijuana
industry is employing,
uh,
like a hundred,
150 people.
Yeah.
Uh,
part time and full time that are along
some rung of the ladder of like,
oh,
well,
you know,
either they're working for the growers
or they're doing the packaging are there
helping with the shipping.
So this is like a huge job creator.
It's a huge money maker.
This is what trump ran on.
Trump's like,
I'm the jobs president.
I'm going to bring jobs back if they go
after this industry.
That's the exact opposite of bringing
jobs back that's shutting jobs down.
Yeah.
What's shutting jobs down though?
With a
kind of people that we don't really want
around the first place?
I mean,
they can,
they can sort of surmise that people
that are running pot shops are probably
pretty left wing,
you know,
pretty,
pretty quickly.
Sure.
So you're making almost,
you're making more money for your
opposition,
whereas the pharmaceutical companies,
they,
they're nonpartisan.
Don't forget the alcohol and just,
yeah,
that's true.
Both of them.
The prison unions,
prison guard unions.
That's what's really crazy.
You find out that prison guard unions
have worked to try to keep marijuana
illegal.
You're like,
wow.
Like what you're really saying is we
want to extract money by putting people
in cages and says,
you're really saying that's what you get
when you do a private prison industry.
Goddammit,
Dj.
I mean,
I've done videos about this fucking
private prison industry.
It's crazy.
And you know,
I'm always surprised by just how tap it,
the responses.
People are like,
Eh,
yeah,
whatever.
You know,
prisoners who gives a shit.
It's like,
yeah,
but what about the fact that plenty of
people don't belong to be there?
What about the fact that these people
who run these prison industries
sponsored legislation to put more people
in jail in a country that already has
the disproportionately highest prison
population of any country on the planet
while claiming to be the fucking land of
the free?
Yeah,
we put a fuck load of people in jail.
Tons.
I think what,
uh,
what is this statistic?
Some,
some bananas thing about the percentage
of people to the United States puts in
jail as opposed to the rest of the
world.
But the rest of the world kills people.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
they don't bother me.
Don't bother locking you up as much in
some other countries.
They just take out in the back and
fucking shoot you in the head.
So you know that mass grave they just
found no,
they found a mass grave in Mexico.
Really,
really bad one.
Apparently they've found has made 200 as
many as 250 bodies.
Cartels or,
yeah.
Yeah.
See if you can find that Jamie.
It's a creepy story man,
because some teachers found it.
They were looking for something else and
they,
I think they just found some bones and
they started digging in and they've only
done like an excavation of a certain
percentage of the land too that they're
looking at and then look,
it might be as much so there could be
extensive mass graves throughout the
entire area.
Sure.
They didn't know this existed.
Here it is more than 250 human skulls
found in Mexico.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Mass grave containing more than 250
human skulls was uncovered in central
Mexico.
Most likely the victim of drug cartels
over the years of Jesus.
Either then or one very prolific serial
killer.
That's a guy who's really getting shit
done.
Yeah.
This is terrifying,
man.
And it's really terrifying that this,
this massive drug war is happening to
fuel the illegal drug market over here
and it's happening with a country that's
connected to us.
It's right there.
It was like this massive issue going on,
right?
Yeah.
And well,
why do you think the build a wall
rhetoric is so effective?
Of course.
Sure.
But it's just even more,
well that's like,
that's like the least effective option.
It's terrible.
It's just the best option
would be to make it legal and regulate
everything and to let adults do whatever
the fuck they want to do.
And if some asshole wants to take math,
let them take math.
Let them by math.
Yeah.
He can buy adderall already.
A lot of these people who are doing
these crazy drugs,
they're only doing it because better
drugs aren't available.
They can't find them.
They're too expensive.
Like,
if you just legalize and regulate all
these markets,
which are,
we know for a fact are going to exist no
matter what because people are just
going to do fucking drugs,
whether it's legal or not legal.
Do you know the only variable?
The only thing that I really worry about
though as opiates because I feel like if
you made opiates legal,
if you made them more accessible,
I just know way too many people have
lost their lives on them.
Yeah.
I know way too many people that have
taken them and then they just,
the whole thing got real slippery and
they just started fucking up at work and
they do,
we're on them all the time and they got
real foggy.
I mean,
look,
we live in a country full of obese
people and uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm pretty obese.
Um,
that's terrible for your health.
Probably not quite as bad as severe
opiate addiction.
Nah,
it's not even close.
But you know,
like it,
it leads to a whole plethora of health
problems.
And look,
I mean,
like we live in either we believe that
people have the freedom to make their
own choices about their own bodies or we
don't.
Right.
And to me,
you know,
even if there is negative repercussions,
negative repercussions to being pro
second amendment,
you know,
we,
we do have more gun violence because of
that.
I still believe in the second amendment.
I do believe in probably more regulation
for it.
But do you just fucked up right there
son?
Yeah,
he's opened up.
The Gates happened opening the gates of
hell.
It's like you're smarter than the
founding fathers.
You're fucking,
were you going to update the Second
Amendment?
I mean,
we've already got the damn waffle house
waiter.
We already updated a plenty of,
uh,
aspects of the constitution.
Not Officially,
but you know,
like the privacy clause that's just
fucking gone.
You know.
So the fourth amendment is just,
you know,
it's,
it's basically no and void at this
point.
I don't want anybody doing heroin,
but I don't think that it should be
illegal.
I just,
I think that stuff,
I,
I bet in certain circumstances under
severe pain,
certain opiates,
especially like natural opiates probably
feel wonderful if you have like a severe
back pain,
you can't rast and you take something
like that and you can,
the real problem is those fucking pills
get in people's DNA,
man.
They,
they get attached to you in some
terrifying way.
Yeah.
And they,
people get into the more than almost
anything I've ever seen.
And they actually are like,
the gateway drug thing is kind of mocked
because it's attributed to weed.
Those pills usually our gateway to,
you know,
begin injecting if they don't inject.
I mean they'll inject if it,
if it works just as good and that's the
only way they can get it.
Yeah.
And that's what happened with a lot of
people in Massachusetts.
It was a,
one of those episodes of Anthony
Bourdain's show,
he was out like near,
I forget what area of Massachusetts,
but it was all about how many people had
been devastated by heroin
addiction and heroin overdoses.
And a lot of it came out of the
oxycontin addictions.
Yeah.
They got the pills really easily.
And then when it became less,
Lindsay started cramp clamping down the
regulations and made it harder for
people to get prescriptions,
then people turn to heroin because they
were addicted to opiates.
Right.
Because a,
it was a nap.
It was just a part of who they were at
that point.
And you know,
the whole country right now,
I mean like,
because of there's a big opiate crisis,
you know,
they're trying to,
doctors are not writing as many of these
opiate prescriptions and if they're
trying to make it harder to get,
so a lot more people are turning to
heroin.
So now we just have a heroin crisis and
people don't know how much to take and
they're overdosing and dying.
It's so spooky and yeah,
but if it was regulated,
um,
you know,
the same people who are already addicted
to it,
who are already going to seek it out or
are you going to find it?
First of all,
there's no stigma so they can actually
go seek fucking treatment for it,
you know?
Right.
It's pretty,
it's pretty difficult to admit you're a
heroin addict when you're scared that
you might go to fucking jail just for
what you do.
Well,
they don't use the best stuff to get
people off drugs anyway.
Yeah.
Supposedly the most effective,
and this is not from my personal
experience,
but the most effective drug to get
people off drugs is that I began stuff I
began,
which is from the Boga Tree.
And uh,
apparently it has a massive impact on
people that are addicted to heroin and
pills and alcoholics and things along
those lines.
Apparently that stuff just fucking
knocked it right out of your system.
Interesting.
And yeah,
and like really excellent rate of,
um,
people staying off of it.
Excellent percentage of people stay off
of it permanently as opposed to a lot of
the other methods.
It's hard for people to change their
ways,
you know,
that people get into these little
patterns and they get into these habits
and if,
if one of those habits also is
physically addicting as well,
like heroin is,
or like pills are.
Yeah.
It's just really hard for people to kick
that shit.
It's terrifying to me,
man.
I understand the kind of,
because I do smoke.
Right.
How much do you smoke?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
at,
at the worst it was probably like two
packs a day.
Oh Dude,
that's a lot.
And um,
you know,
now it's probably like half a pack a
day.
That's better.
I've been down though to as low as like
three or four cigarettes a day.
Why don't you just limit yourself to
something like that?
Uh,
cause the only way I can actually do it
is to get my girlfriend or my brother or
somebody to Dole them out to me cause I
don't have the willpower to just say I
ain't going to do it.
What if you like?
And then he puts a lot of stress on them
to have to regulate it and me fucking
bothering them and I'll,
I'll fucking deviously just like sneak
out and go to the gas station had like
another pack.
So I'm smoking those four,
but I'm also secretly smoking like
another four or five off somewhere else.
Well that's ridiculous.
Yeah,
I'm terrible.
that's absolutely awful.
Do you,
uh,
have a problem with that type of
behavior or accepted?
No,
no,
no.
I realize when I'm doing it like,
wow,
I'm a total piece of shit for doing
this.
You,
you know,
is it just the moment feel so good to
suck on that cigarette to feed?
It's really not because it's fucking
horrible.
Every time I smoke a cigarette,
I'm like,
why am I doing this?
Huh.
But what happens is there's that moment
before or more than a moment,
like the,
the lead up to smoking a cigarette.
It's like,
God damn,
pet cigarette.
When I get it,
it's going to be so fucking good.
Really.
It's going to make me feel just fine and
all this.
And then I start smoking.
I'm like,
man,
this fucking sucks.
And then I put all smoke it or I'll
smoke half of it and put it out or
whatever.
And then,
you know,
next thing I know,
30 minutes to an hour later it's like,
man,
that next cigarette I smoke,
it's going to be so fucking nice.
Oh,
okay.
So it's the feeling before the cigarette
that you,
the anticipation and the immediate
reward is what the immediate reward is.
Like.
Disappointment.
Really.
It's just like,
this sucks.
This is,
this doesn't taste good.
This isn't really changing my brain
chemistry in a significant enough way.
It looks cool though.
It,
you know what rebel,
the visual element is nice.
I like seeing the smoke just fucking
climb up and shit.
Yeah.
That big fucking little stream of smoke
and it curls around and gets bigger and
does all those fucking little weird
acrobatics and shit.
But it does put you into a certain
mindset if you're acknowledging that
you're doing something absolutely
ridiculous.
This detrimental to your health.
Yeah,
no,
it is.
There's no,
there's no debate.
There's no division,
not a terrible it,
and you're like,
I'm going to fuck as naive and I don't
give a fuck though.
I'm just,
I'm just fucking stupid.
It's just like,
wow,
I'm just a fucking drone for this shit.
It's a little bit of that,
but it's a little bit of,
I want this cigarette in my body right
now more than I want to be healthy
later.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's true.
Cause you're healthy enough to smoke it.
Instant gratification.
Instant.
You'd just given a little piece of
yourself to death.
Just a little piece.
Yeah.
Just let me take a little piece.
Ego Death.
Yeah.
You're just going to give you a little
bit of my life force.
You just take that and in exchange I'll
puff on this stupid.
Yeah.
It's like there's a bank of stick of
leaves.
How much she put in.
How much do you take out and when
you're,
when you're smoking cigarettes,
you're greedy.
Who take a lot out of your account.
Yeah.
Just digging into your account and all
of sudden,
you know,
you go to the shop and you're like,
yeah,
can I get this on credit?
And like,
dude,
you're out of credit.
Oh it's over.
Damn,
you fucked up your lung son.
He burnt them off.
Yeah.
That's really what kind of,
what it is.
Right.
I agree.
I don't have any argument with that
analogy.
I don't know.
Wouldn't say stop doing it if you don't,
if you don't feel like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm uh,
uh,
I went to my fucking a doctor recently
and they,
they gave me a book and I haven't read
it yet,
but it's supposedly it's going to help.
So on cigarettes.
Yeah.
I'm Mike Lacey who owns a comedy and
magic club.
His wife works with people that have
terminal lung cancer.
Yeah.
And he was explaining how they die and
he's explaining that you're essentially,
you're drowning in your own fluid and
that you're,
you're,
you're gasping for air as you leave this
life.
Yeah.
He goes and people are in sheer horror
and terror and he said,
it is not something you ever want to do.
The fucking,
uh,
the smokers war or some shit,
man,
maybe should I fit.
Thing is when they go bad,
they go bad away from us.
They go bad there in those hospitals
somewhere locked up in a room and the
nurses get to see them and they'll tell
you the nurses are the ones once you
talk to,
if you want to find out how horrible it
is to watch someone die from lung
cancer.
Yeah.
Well the way Mike Lacey was explaining
it to brian red band,
but meanwhile went right in there and
write out there and fell on the ground.
Yeah.
You know,
that could happen.
Right.
And hit by a bus tomorrow,
but not live forever anyway.
Yeah.
Just too much,
too much a desire to get that,
that feel.
It's also,
it's like a rebellious attitude that
goes with it.
I don't give a fuck about my health.
Why do I give a fuck about anything?
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I do have problems,
uh,
finding like things to be passionate
about or care about.
Um,
but I guess in some ways I've tried to
cultivate that because you know,
like George Carlin and shit.
Yeah.
Like I loved that idea of,
yeah.
I'm just,
I'm an observer here.
Like,
I'm not going to be part of this.
I'm just going to look at it from the
outside and be detached from it.
And I've tried to,
I've kind of tried to cultivate that in
myself,
but I've also noticed like it's kind of
hard to,
to draw upon my own passions the more I
do that.
So I don't know if I need to find a
happier medium or what.
But that's interesting.
So in your analysis of a subject,
like when you're doing these youtube
videos,
you almost like an outsider looking in
and you,
you feel like there's like,
there's like a good strategy to that
maybe are a good,
uh,
I think it's,
I try to make it,
I guess I try to use it as like a thing
to bolster objectivity.
Like I don't want to be just saying what
the crowd wants to hear,
right?
I don't want to be a just saying things
because I think like this is gonna be
the most entertaining or whatever.
Like I want it to be like,
here's what I really fucking think about
this.
And I think you have to have like some
kind of a wall of detachment because you
know,
people aren't always going to react well
to it and shit too.
Yeah,
that's a really good point.
You almost have to be in this sort of
antisocial place because you,
if you're too social with these people,
you won't judge them correctly.
I mean like,
look,
people are very worried about,
um,
especially lately about like advertising
and Shit influencing,
uh,
what people do and say,
but like,
people don't really realize that it's,
it's,
it's really just as much of a danger to
become beholden to the audience or to
the
mob and to go along with,
here's the,
here's what we really want to hear from
you for sure.
And it's like,
well,
maybe I might be what you want to hear,
but that's not what I'm gonna fucking
say.
Hey Tj,
how about you stick to this?
Yeah,
exactly.
To go back to your lane,
what's your lane,
Bro?
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure you sound like you've
experienced this as well.
Look,
there are a lot of people out there in
this world and if you want to get
opinions from every single one of them
and consider them individually without
meeting any of those people,
to me that's shitty data.
Okay.
That's not good data.
If I know you,
I've talked to you.
If you tell me something and you're
smart guy,
I'll consider,
I'll be like,
okay,
well I know Tj and Tj was saying that he
wouldn't be saying it if he didn't
believe it.
So I have to think about what he's
saying and I'll have to go through my
head and find out whether or not I agree
with them.
I'd have to objectively look at it.
You could be talking to a million insane
people.
You really,
there's no way you could individually
react to each one of them,
but you can get a sense of whether or
not people were upset at you or not.
Oh,
sure.
It can get a sense of whether or not
logical people make sense.
Like that makes sense.
Feel like you've crossed a line.
Look,
I've,
I've noticed this really weird shift in
the Zeit geist um,
in the last like year or so.
Um,
and it kind of started with this whole
fake news thing.
You know,
the left was saying the trump got in
because of fake news and then trump
saying,
oh,
they'll all the attacks against me or
fake news.
And uh,
I've seen on Youtube,
I'm like,
we used to do this kayfabe stuff on our
show.
Kayfabe is like wrestling talk for like,
you know,
fake,
the,
the pageantry of it.
Like we're just pretending drama and
shit.
We used to do it all the time on my
show,
the drunken peasants podcast.
Suddenly people turned on it.
They're like,
we don't want this anymore.
And it's it,
you know,
and I got,
I got shit because I did this,
a sponsored ad for this app called
candid.
And people are like,
you know,
everything you say is bullshit because
you did this sponsored spot for candid,
and you're fucking a shill.
So we dismiss you.
And it's because everyone's on this big
fucking authenticity kick.
But they're not really actually
skeptical though.
They're,
they're just,
they just want a demagogue to spew.
Like,
here's what you already think is true.
I am here to validate all of your
feelings and all of your opinions.
And a lot of these people seem to want
me to be that,
but I'm not that.
Yeah,
they,
they're going to want you to form to
whatever their opinion of you is.
And if you deviate from that,
there's going to be a certain amount of
people that are going to be upset,
but it's up to you to,
to figure out,
like what is the worst thing,
I think for any,
any performer or artist is to get boxed
into like kind of a fake thing.
Like maybe a character that you do or
something along those lines and then you
can't get out of it.
Rick James Bitch.
Yeah.
Well like,
yeah,
like Bobcat goldthwait had the hardest
time because he had that I,
you know,
the character that he would do with
screaming and yelling bobcat character.
Yeah.
And then he wanted to just eventually b
Bob Goldthwaite and people like,
no,
fuck that man.
Where's the bobcat thing?
Like it took him years to get away from
that.
He got his films by the way.
Oh,
it's,
films are great.
Did you see the big foot movie know
Willow Creek?
It's haven't seen any horror movie.
It's really good.
Is it?
It's,
he did it like a Blair witch project
type thing of these people up there,
a sasquatch hunting.
And,
uh,
look,
I don't want to say anymore,
but I'm pretty skeptic.
I'm,
I'm like a big skeptic.
I don't believe in a lot of this stuff,
but I'm really fascinated by things like
big foot and aliens and the lochness
monster in the flat earth and the hollow
worth and all this stuff.
Don't believe in any of it.
In fact,
I think most of it's like totally
fucking ridiculous.
But I find it really fascinating,
um,
because I kind of view it as like almost
like modern mythology.
You know,
you,
you kind of see the genesis of how
people talk.
You know,
people used to talk about like suck
buses coming in in the night and you
know,
stealing their,
their essence and shit and seducing
them,
you know?
Um,
and you kind of see like the modern
versions of that is like the alien that
takes you up and it was ship and shoves
a probe up your ass or whatever.
Yeah.
Well I think alien,
the alien thing absolutely has something
to do with dreaming 100%,
because a giant percentage of these
abduction events occur when someone's
either napping or when someone's
sleeping.
It's a,
they're always unconscious sleep
paralysis.
Yeah.
Well,
it's not even just that.
It's,
it's probably psychedelic compound
compounds that are released in the brain
during rem sleep.
The reason why you have these wacky
fucking dreams,
I mean,
you have dreams that are so insane.
They're like a psychedelic trip.
Yeah.
Like an imagination.
It has control of the psychedelic
chemicals,
a power your brain and runs you on a
trip.
I mean,
that's where are,
or,
um,
I had,
uh,
I don't really suffer from it too bad
anymore,
but like in,
in my late teens and early twenties,
I had really bad sleep paralysis.
Whoa.
And,
uh,
also,
a company that was a,
I forget if it's called hypnopompic
hallucinations or hypnagogic
hallucinations,
but,
um,
I could tell you right,
you know,
like,
uh,
I'll be laying in bed or I would be at
the time and,
um,
I would kind of wake up but I wouldn't
be able to move my body.
And then,
you know,
and,
and aside from that,
you feel the overwhelming sense of like
there's another presence here and it's
ominous and you fucking,
uh,
if you have the hypnagogic
hallucinations or hypnopompic
hallucinations that there one is when
you're,
you hallucinate as you're going into
sleep.
One is when you loosening as they're
coming out,
I have the one where you hallucinate or
coming out of sleep.
So I would wake up and uh,
probably the first time it happened I
was 11 and I saw this robe to figure
like walk across my bedroom.
And then when I was 15,
what did it look like?
A real thing.
Oh yeah.
Like it looked totally real.
It didn't look like it was transparent,
right?
No,
no,
no.
It just like,
it didn't look like a dude.
Cause there was like four feet tall.
Oh look,
a gnome.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I assumed it was like,
because my uncle is a big Ufo guy,
so I'm like,
I saw an alien and at the time I was
convinced to that.
Later I became more skeptical and when I
was like 15 I woke up and I saw this
fucking a figure standing at the foot of
my bed.
You ever seen the movie dark city?
Yes.
It did that sleep thing from dark city
and I was like,
okay.
And I went back to sleep.
Holy Shit.
I woke up the next morning.
I'm like,
uh,
if that happens again,
I'm going to fucking tackle this thing.
You sure that wasn't just a dream?
Uh,
I'm pretty sure I was awake because the
fall,
the fall of two weeks later I saw it
again and I did like,
I plan to do,
I fucking jumped up and I tried to
tackle it.
It just kind of disappeared in my arms
when I got to it too.
And I was like,
okay,
well that was okay.
I'm,
I was relieved because I'm like,
it was obviously a hallucination and I
look up and it's fucking head is
floating there and it just done this
head vanishes.
Whoa.
Um,
but these are just hallucinations.
I mean maybe,
maybe if they're not houses hard
interdimensional beings,
how do you know cause uh,
sound so confident.
I've read pretty extensively about it.
Cause like when that shit happens to
you,
you want to know like what's going on
here.
So when they can,
they can induce that state and uh,
you know,
like they can put you into sleep
paralysis and you'll feel the presence
and you'll experience seeing things and
all that stuff.
They can put you in that mindset.
It's a matter of electrically
stimulating certain areas of the scalp.
Right.
Yeah.
Which is really fascinating,
isn't it?
That they can actually target areas of
the scalp and induce certain feelings
and certain thoughts.
Yeah.
We kind of delved into this last time we
talked.
Yeah.
Consciousness and the afterlife,
things of that nature.
I wonder though,
like what would cause you to recall like
an image from a really fucking cool
movie like that?
And have it be like what would weird
combination of things would cause,
you know like when I was reading causes
a hallucination to take a certain storm.
Like what is it?
Is it your insecurities and fears is
you're,
you're nightmarish vision of,
it's the same thing that leads you to
have certain visions and dreams and
things.
I mean like it's part of your memory and
psychology just manifest imagination as
well.
Yeah.
Like A,
there was a guy,
uh,
I was reading about his experiences and
he,
he would see the,
the,
the guy from the front of the extra
poster.
Oh,
Shannon,
his room.
He'd see that that silhouette holding
the,
the briefcase and Shit and looking up at
the bill.
The building dude,
when I was a kid,
that movie was fucking terrifying.
Like you could watch it today and never
fully impact what it did to people like
me.
What year is that?
Like I want to say it was like 76 does
that make sense?
Which means I was like nine years old.
Find out what,
what year the extras this was,
what year was that?
I remember seeing the 25th anniversary.
73 isn't like 73,
so I was younger than that.
Who the fuck?
Let me watch that.
That's ridiculous.
Mom,
mom,
how dare you?
But uh,
I remember being scared out of my
fucking mind at this movie.
Yeah,
there's that.
There's the image that movie fucked with
my head for years and I started thinking
about demons and the idea of being
possessed and what could happen.
Yeah.
He watched it today.
You'll laugh your ass off.
Oh yeah.
I was watching,
I was watching that movie a at my
uncle's house and my mom came in the
room and she,
she's like really easily frightened and
stuff and she just thought it was
hilarious.
The extra assist is hilarious.
I mean,
it's funny by today's standard,
but like if you go watch it in the
context of like watch horror movies that
came around around the same time and
before it,
and it's like,
okay,
you can kind of see why this blew
people's minds at the time.
Well,
when it happened,
when that movie came out,
they had never been anything like on
that level.
We're a little cute little girl had,
becomes a demon and starts ramming
across and do her pussy.
Yeah.
Just fuck me father.
Fuck my father's slamming.
Which saint fuck me.
Jesus.
Which what did she,
she was just saying fuck me.
I don't remember whether she was like,
fuck me.
Fuck me.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I like what she's like,
yeah.
I'm not a Saas Cox and hell yeah.
It was a beautiful moment in cinematic
history.
I couldn't believe that that was
actually in a movie that they said that
in a movie.
Yeah.
I mean like she was having trouble
getting away with that fucking now given
the age of the actress.
Oh,
they wouldn't be allowed to.
It would be illegal now.
It would,
it would be illegal.
No,
no,
it didn't,
it didn't like show anything.
Uh,
but yeah,
it would probably be controversial even
if it was made.
Just making that little kid act like
that.
Yeah.
Look at those pictures of her,
like when she was screaming and yelling,
first of all,
that little kid was fucking terrifyingly
good.
Oh yeah.
And you know,
the,
they,
uh,
she was,
they didn't have much,
well,
like care for her wellbeing or anything
either.
Cause like,
you know,
that scene where she's spasming and
flopping up and down.
They were doing that with wires and that
fucked her backup for life.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Total disregard for,
for her safety or wellbeing.
Fucked her backup for life when she was
a little kid making his movie.
Yup.
Wow.
Like what did it do to her back?
Do you know specifically?
I don't know.
It just gave her back back issues.
I don't know if they were severe or
what,
but she,
something got polled or something got
out of alignment.
I mean,
you saw how violently they had flopping
up and down on that bed.
Yeah.
That's not good.
So,
you know,
the,
the standards were different,
I guess at the time,
but,
but uh,
I think most people should realize,
don't,
uh,
don't permanently injure a child just to
get an effect.
You want in a movie.
My kids are watching this TV show.
It's like an old Disney show called good
luck,
Charlie.
Yeah.
And Charlie's a little baby.
It's a baby.
Baby is the cutest little baby,
but it's a baby.
Yeah,
like maybe a year old or maybe two at
the most like it's tiny little thing.
And that's the bane character.
Like imagine like not only do you not
get to choose whether or not you want to
be famous,
want to be an actor cause you're a
fucking baby.
You can't even talk yet.
You're already on tv but the whole
show's about you so you can't quit.
Yeah.
And you know,
I was wondering like it when I'm
watching movies,
like you see babies like crying and
stuff and you know like how they make
that baby cry,
they bite them.
Does this seem ethical?
It doesn't really seem ethical.
Definitely not ethical.
It's fucked up man.
That's why when people are like make fun
of that a American sniper movie for
using that little shitty plastic baby.
Oh it was obviously fake.
I'm like whatever.
It's better than fucking having some
real kid and getting it to cry and stuff
and whatever.
I blame clinics went on that.
Like you should have phrased that better
to frame away from that.
You could have sold it better.
Yeah,
you could.
You could have filmed that in a
different way.
He films things a lot of times in a very
sort of traditional way.
Yeah,
he's a great director and everything
like that.
But how the hell did he not see that
rubber baby?
They'll look so funny.
He's pretty old,
you know,
give him,
give him a little,
I guess,
but somebody there with them in the
editing room,
going home,
street swept off.
It's rubber baby.
It's pretty obvious.
Who's going to,
who's going to tell dirty harry that the
scene doesn't work?
Did you know?
I know,
I got it.
Remember when,
uh,
that whole movie was,
that was a weird time when that movie
came out.
That was like a movie where you had to
say you liked it.
If you didn't say you liked it,
you risk violence.
I just,
I just didn't see it,
so I seen it.
I've seen it since then,
but at the time I didn't watch it.
It just wasn't a very good movie.
Now a lot of people love the movie and
to them it was really good.
To me it was,
it was,
it was like so much,
and this is probably my personal bias of
like being out here and being in
Hollywood and knowing how writers work
and knowing how,
you know,
like they,
they structure these things and how
this,
what kind of effect the studio wants to
have on the audience.
For big mainstream movie,
you could feel like the heavy hand of of
Hollywood all over it and you could feel
like the way they were,
the wording,
the things that he said and the just all
the whole thing was like so affected.
It's like I'm,
I'm not getting a good sense of what
this guy's real life.
It was propaganda.
Yeah.
And then you know,
and then you find out about the Jesse
Ventura thing where Jesse Ventura sued
him because he made up some story and
them up.
And apparently there was a few other
stories that weren't true as well that
were in that book that fucked a Jesse
venture is a career up a little bit too.
Yeah.
He was just don,
he was talking about it.
It cost him over a million dollars in
legal fees.
Yeah.
And he's been doing it for what,
four years now.
Got a judgment in his favor,
but then they,
they did shift lead,
took it away somehow.
I forget.
They lost on appeal.
It's not good.
The whole thing is not good because hey,
he's a hero.
Well
it's,
it's really,
it's just,
you know,
the truth is truth and you,
you can't just make stuff up about
people and you know,
maybe he should've dropped the lawsuit
when the guy died.
You know,
maybe that would have been better for
everybody,
but that this his decision,
he felt like he was wrong.
Then he felt like he was going after the
publishers.
When the legend becomes truth print the
legend.
Yeah.
Sorry.
It's just,
I think also you're dealing with the
pressures of war being so alien to most
people that when you and I who have not
been to war,
sit,
sit around talking and debating about
what it's like to be like the most
decorated sniper ever.
Or a guy who experiences that much
action and sees that much death and to
really try to rationalize what goes in
and out of their mind and like what
their grasp on reality is like.
And then there's also the opportunity
that this guy has.
If you're leaving the military and
writing a book,
why not just make a bunch of crazy shit
up and make it even better to sell more
fucking books?
You know?
I mean it's very possible that someone
would take that attitude like,
look,
I'm not going to tell you most of the
truth anyway cause it's not in your
business.
And it's,
some of it might be classified and some
of them might be illegal for me to talk
about,
but maybe I'll make up a bunch of crazy
shit,
sell some bucks.
Now I'm on the selling me stage of my
life.
Yeah.
You know,
and look,
he was probably always doing that to
some extent,
you know,
because you didn't,
you don't become the,
the top American sniper unless you
already have a preconceived notion of
yourself as like,
I'm this bad ass and I'm this great
warrior.
And anything you can say to add to that,
you're gonna,
you're gonna say,
well,
I think maybe more,
maybe you could just be a badass sniper,
right?
Can you just be just some dude who just
excels?
Well,
I mean,
but you look at his character in this,
the sort of stories these made up and
shit,
and it's obvious that,
you know,
while he did have actual skills,
he was also fond of embellishing the
skills he did have to make himself even
more legendary.
Yeah.
And why is the question,
you know,
because there are people that think that
the horrors of war,
like we talked about,
bend the mind and Ben Perception and
Ben,
the way you look at reality and in some
people more severe ways and other
people.
Sure.
It's,
uh,
the,
the I,
the request or the,
the,
the task that we give young people where
they go off to war at fucking 18 years
of age and we ship
them off,
get them to shoot people and then
comeback and integrate and try to be a
normal part of society.
And then with almost no education,
almost no assistance,
no help.
No,
no.
Karen them along.
No.
You know,
you mean she'd be looking at them and
talking to him very carefully.
You've asked him to do
crazy thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
especially at the,
the,
you know,
like 18 is around the time when I was
just willing to dump like pancakes on
some dude's lap because he fucking,
you know,
set across thing to me.
So to take people at that age and who
haven't even really,
I mean,
I guess they've kind of reached the age
of reason and stuff,
uh,
in the eyes of society,
but you know,
they're,
they're not like fully formed adult
minds yet.
It's like,
hey,
you're,
you're pretty much still a kid in a lot
of ways.
Go overseas and kill some other people's
fucking kids.
Let's just see what happens.
You know,
let's try over there and blow some
brains out.
Oh,
you blew out more brains than anyone
else.
You're a hero.
You're great.
It's a weird way of looking at it,
but that's,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
You know,
when you're asking someone to do
something before there a certain age,
like you're,
you have a certain amount of authority
over a 17 year old or an 18 year old.
When you give them a gun and tell them
that they're supposed to do it,
they believe they're supposed to do it
because you're older and you tell them
that they're supposed to do it.
So reason why 40 year old guys don't
sign up for the army because when a
guy's 40 might have a family of his own,
might have a life of,
as long as they're like,
wait,
what?
Why the fuck are we going over there?
What are these guys done to us?
Hold on,
hold on.
When are we charging a dawn with the
plan?
Like you're going to ask questions and
I've going to just trust you at face
value and that's no good.
It's terrible.
Well you want,
when you want soldiers,
you want someone who just listens.
Yeah.
Who are you listening to though?
Like who were you listening to and why
you listen to that guy and what,
how'd you get into this situation?
Well,
they don't think about that.
They're fucking 18.
It's just asking people to go from that
to regular life.
It's such a bizarre request.
Yeah.
My stepdad tried to get me to join the
uh,
the military when I was younger cause
he's like,
he saw me and like your life has no
direction.
You know what?
You need military.
I thought about doing it.
I didn't really give it much thought.
I went to the recruiting office and let
them give me a sales pitch.
But yeah,
I'll see you went that far.
I never went into her acuity recruiting
office.
Thank God I took a test and they're
like,
you could be a,
you know,
military intelligence.
I'm like,
Eh,
but I heard that a lot of times they
sucker you in with that.
Like you're going to be military
intelligence.
Then if you don't cut it,
they're like,
well,
you didn't cut it.
You're a grunt now.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
I've heard that recruiters will bullshit
you and tell you they're going to get
you some cool job inside the military
and then once you get in there they give
you or fuck the job.
They were thinking about giving you in
the first place,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
They don't,
it's not like a college where you,
you know,
yeah,
you get to choose your major and all
this,
none of that.
No.
They,
they'll decide in many ways it's like
it's sort of communist in a way,
you know,
you get paid very little.
He worked very hard.
Everything is for company.
Yeah.
You know,
it's really kind of weird.
Yeah.
Well America has a a strange
relationship with that sort of
collectivism when you think about it
that way.
Like it has to probably be that way in
order for you to function together.
A soldier's.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't think you,
I don't think you really want a unit
where everyone's constantly questioning
orders and you know,
like,
no,
I mean,
as much as we kind of placed value on
that,
like,
you know,
it's good to think for yourself and it's
good to question things.
Um,
if you're trying to be an effective
military,
it's,
that's not what's good.
What's good is you do what your fucking
told.
Exactly.
So that's probably why they use 18 year
olds to begin with.
But the problem is,
you know,
even if we're going to accept the
reality that that's how it has to be,
there has to be more oversight about
where are we going to send these people?
What reasons have to be in place for us
to send these people.
And you know,
we're,
we're still at,
now that we're still in Iraq,
we're still in Afghanistan.
Obama during his presidency,
bombed a seven countries with drone
strikes.
Uh,
by the way,
I don't know if you've ever seen the,
the report that like 90% of drone
strikes didn't kill their intended
targets,
90% civilian casualties.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
so,
uh,
terribly ineffectual.
Like why our country is like spreading
bad will across the world,
especially in the Middle East,
which is like a hotbed of fucking crazy
fucks anyway.
Just doing it that way in general robots
flying from the sky.
Oh look,
you got,
you gotta make sure those things work.
Like if you're going to just,
you can't be that off where you're
killing.
I mean it was,
it's in the high 80%,
wasn't it last time we checked with the,
uh,
the civilian casualty rate was
unintended casualties for drone strikes
and you know,
like if you have any weapon that has
like 10% effectiveness at killing its
target,
you know,
like that's not a good weapon.
That's a piece of shit.
It's just w but we're like,
yeah,
but listen,
this way we don't have to send soldiers
and we just fly it in and we just shoot
the missiles and we get the fuck out of
there.
Yeah,
that's really what I'm saying.
I can see the appeal of that,
but make sure the technology is there
and in a way it might be like the most
racist way to kill people.
Yeah.
We're not even willing a whisk at risk
our own lives to kill you.
We're just going to kill you from afar.
And we were not as concerned about
killing civilians because no one's,
they're doing it cause we're all the way
in Nevada with a fucking xbox
controller.
Yeah.
And everyone were killing is just some,
some brown Muslim people.
So it's okay.
Okay.
Nearly 90% of the people killed in
airstrikes were not the intended
targets,
you know.
And some of these still might have been
bad people.
I mean they're hanging around with
fucking,
you know,
or they might have Eris and shit.
Some of them were,
I mean we saw in the Yemen raid a,
the plenty of those victims were kids.
Is there footage of a drone like
watching a drone shoot down something is
there,
I want to see what it looks like.
See if you could pull up a video.
Is it from the drones point of view or
is it,
it is people seeing the,
usually,
usually you'll see it from the drone
perspective.
I would like to see what it looks like.
Like a drone launch.
Something like if you were on the
ground,
you saw a drone launch,
something in the distance.
Here we go.
Just,
yeah,
that's what it usually is like.
So dehumanized,
boom,
boom.
You're dead insane too.
I mean,
the way it just,
some dudes walking down the street and
then the Ambo Book,
look at that guy.
He's moved.
Oh my God.
You imagine that just walking down the
street due to due to do,
boom.
You're dead.
Fucking fiery.
Fire ball of death consumes you
instantly.
Oh Man.
Incinerated off the face of the fucking
earth.
Well,
that Wiki leaks one,
the first one.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
You see,
I'm trying to get away and shit.
Collateral murder.
Remember they call it the collateral
murder.
Yeah.
Put that video out and you got to see
like how they're reacting to gutting
these people down the street and they
find out it's the wrong people.
Yeah.
It's like,
whoops.
Yeah.
Like,
wow.
And that this got out and it shouldn't
have gotten out.
You know,
that's the,
that was the big wikileaks rub.
Right.
They shouldn't have released that.
We shouldn't know.
Yeah.
We shouldn't know when our tax dollars
fund,
uh,
the murder of civilians,
the accidental unintended murder of a
guy with a camera that you thought was a
gun yet.
But when you,
when you,
when you see this statistic that 90% of
these strikes are killing the wrong
people.
I mean,
you know,
I mean like,
it's happening all the time,
but isn't it crazy how shit their optics
are that they can't tell the difference
between a rifle and a camera at
distance?
Yeah.
And it's not even just the optics to is
just bits is bad intelligence.
Like they'll,
they'll just,
because they don't have to actually risk
any troops.
Yeah.
They'll just be like,
someone says like,
yeah,
I think he's at this house.
Oh,
okay.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Yeah,
that's true.
Right.
If they were on the ground,
they wouldn't treat it that way.
If they were on the ground and we saw
people on the ground,
they were walking down the street and
they saw the photographer with the,
with the camera,
they probably wouldn't treat it and it
does.
No Way.
They would just open fire and gun
everybody down as soon as they saw the
people.
Yeah.
So you just,
you just gone everybody down that you
run into on your way to the bad guys.
It bad guys.
But when it,
when it's,
when you have that level of detachment
where it's like,
oh,
this is like a fucking video game.
Oops,
I killed some,
uh,
I killed some civilians.
Okay,
well the ducks and points from the
scoreboard.
Yeah,
because if you were on the ground and
the same thing happened,
wouldn't you be judged differently?
Like if you are on the ground and you
are moving down the street and you saw a
bunch of people in front of you and one
guy had a camera and you just gun them
all down,
the women,
the kids,
everybody in front of them.
Yeah.
And you're like,
well,
you know,
hey,
they shouldn't have been out here with
their kids.
And uh,
I didn't think that was the camera.
Well,
that's essentially,
is that exactly what the guy said from
the helicopter,
right?
Yeah,
but it's different.
It's because there's a level of
detachment.
There's that wall of separation,
that wall of separation.
It's kind of fucked.
Oh,
it's terrible.
It's scary.
90%.
90.
So let's just keep doing it that way
then.
For sure.
We're going to,
there's nothing we can do about it.
Uh,
look at it.
This is what I'm,
what I'm,
when I went,
when I talk about that,
when I talk about this,
when I talk about the collusion between
the Democrats and the Republicans,
this is the kind of shit I'm talking
about.
This doesn't stop military stuff.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
this stuff doesn't seem to stop.
Whether it's D or R,
right?
This military,
this American Empire that we're trying
to maintain across the globe,
that keeps happening.
That's actually a very good point
because that stays consistent.
And the battle over transgender
bathrooms take front page of the news
and then the,
but the war aspect of it stays
consistent.
The drone aspects days consistent.
If it doesn't ramp up and it looks like
it's ramping up a little bit with trump.
Right.
Maybe.
I think that remains to be seen.
Yeah,
it does.
It,
Obama's been pretty,
Obama Obama was pretty bad about it.
I mean he was extremely violent.
Uh,
drone strikes increased under him.
And that's some of that's just because
the technology improved.
Well,
there's a lot of things about him that
were so confusing.
The drone strikes is just one of them.
How about the attacks on whistleblowers?
Like whatever happened and what you said
in your shit like yet that hope and
change website,
like the whole thing was going to give
an offer protection to whistle blowers.
Well,
you have like one of the biggest whistle
blowers in the history of the world.
Yet the idea of transparency to that was
like a big thing.
He transparency,
transparency,
but then you prosecute whistleblowers
who revealed the gay illegal activities
of the government.
That's why when trump was like,
he wiretapped trump tower.
I'm like,
so what he wiretapped America,
the NSA was instill is like just
gathering everyone's text messages.
Everyone's phone calls,
archiving that shit in a big server
somewhere.
So it hasn't,
how's he walked that back though?
Hasn't he said now that he doesn't think
that it was a wire tap that it was mike
something else.
Yeah,
sure.
But the point is that all the,
all the phones are fucking tapped
course.
So what does it matter?
Yeah.
That information is already there.
And you know,
the,
the crazy thing is that not only is it
there for those agencies,
but it's there for anyone who can hack
into those agencies to get,
and you know,
if the cio at the,
the,
uh,
the NSA developed it,
the CIA,
we now know,
has its own version of it.
I wonder how many private companies have
their own version of this fucking
server.
Yeah.
When we found out that the CIA has their
own version of it,
everybody was like,
well,
what them to done,
todd?
Well,
they're even worse than the NSA.
So how would you know?
Well,
I mean,
I guess I can't,
I guess I can't say with certainty
they're worse,
but the NSA has never been involved as
far as I know,
in toppling the democratically elected
leaders of other countries and
installing puppets that are good for
American business interests.
So the CIA has,
yes.
Numerous times.
Yeah.
The,
the idea of them all being able to
listen to anybody's telephone calls were
regardless of whether or not you're a
terrorist,
felon,
regardless of whether or not he was the
nicest person of all time,
they're like,
Yep,
let me just check.
Yep.
You're still the nicest guy of all time.
And they're using it for,
uh,
I mean,
it's not just being used for terrorism.
Me,
they're using it for,
there's through their drug war as well.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
um,
the drug war is going to have to ramp up
if this marijuana legalization keeps
kicking in,
they're going to have to figure out some
other way to arrest people.
They have to keep the same jobs.
I mean,
they have a lot of jobs.
They're going to have to justify,
I mean,
jeff sessions could come to the pot
shops like where I live and uh,
I guess there's pot shops around here
too and uh,
and they could fucking
read them.
They could shut them down.
Yeah,
they could legally,
yeah.
They're the,
because it's still illegal under federal
law.
Obama chose not to do that.
He chose her respect the will of the
states,
but the trump administration has at
least signaling that it's not going to
because of sessions.
You think because of a point.
I don't think it's just because of
sessions.
I think sessions is where he is
partially because they want to do this
crackdown.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
You might be right.
We'll have to find out about that,
but the crackdown is not going to go
well.
It's a terrible idea.
You let the genie out of the bottle,
you gave people their freedom.
That will be the,
that'll be the death of a,
of the power of the trump
administration.
If they actually go through with
something so stupid.
It would be stupid economically as well.
Oh yeah.
It would show.
I mean,
you want to talk about transparency,
it will show really clearly who your
loyalty is to that it's not to the will
of the people that it's to these
companies that are benefiting from
keeping marijuana illegal.
Period.
That's it.
And then we'd have to figure out a
marijuana coalition.
We've,
we've got to figure out a way,
like there are fucking 100 million of
us.
I guarantee you in this country,
100 million people that smoked pot.
That's a lot of fucking people and that
number's going to grow a third of the
country.
It's,
yeah.
And it's going to grow.
The more things are people are
jubilee room.
Really believe you fucking idiot.
You fucking point.
There's a lot of fucking people.
I might've made that number up.
I fucking,
uh,
I mean,
I believe it.
I believe it's probably at least close
because even when I was living down
south and I was hanging out with
conservatives who love trump,
they smoked a little weed,
smoking weed,
not a little weed.
They're smoking weed like crazy.
It's fun.
It's fun to get high.
There's nothing wrong with it.
The only thing that's wrong with it is
the fact that it's been buttoned down
into our brain,
deep,
deep in our memory through propaganda
that it's bad for you.
That's it.
Yeah.
If you looked at the actual effects it
has on you,
like we were talking about schizophrenia
and blaming marijuana on schizophrenia,
but it still seems across the board it'd
be 1% it's the same thing with dummies
and lazy people.
When dummies and lazy people find out
about pot,
it ruins the idea of it for other
people.
Oh,
well look,
it's associated with his loud mouth
dummy.
His loud mouth,
fucking lazy person never gets anything
done.
He's always broke.
So I was asking for money.
That's a pothead.
Potheads don't get shit done.
Don't be a pothead.
And then you get that in your head and
you're just run with it.
Well,
there's plenty of men.
We know there's plenty of potheads that
are really industrious and hardworking.
You know a lot of them,
you can't attribute something that was
always part of someone's personality and
say,
well,
marijuana cause that.
Exactly.
It doesn't totally change the nature of
a person.
It's not that powerful of a fucking
drug.
Nor does coffee.
No.
Nor does alcohol nor do cigarettes for
that matter.
Exactly.
Well,
alcohol can change some people.
That's true.
It was bad example.
Canada justice system is crumbling as
cannabis rates continue.
So,
um,
there've been,
there had been busted all these fucking
pot places.
I thought you guys had your social
justice warrior president and uh,
everybody was going to get to pick their
own gender pronouns and now you're
aerating pot places.
Kaloga this 6,500 cases in provincial
court could be soon drop due to delays
including 38 for homicide or attempted
murderer.
One terrible case last year,
a man named Kenneth Williamson was
convicted of raping a minor over a
hundred times.
But because of lengthly delays and
taking his truck,
his case to trial,
his conviction was overturned.
Wait,
is that so they could prosecute more
marijuana?
No,
this is just saying that they are there.
They're there.
They're system is in such crisis and
this marijuana case where they're
arresting all these people from
marijuana,
it's insane because their justice system
is already in the crisis.
So it says,
considering the justice system crisis,
cannabis should obviously be the lowest
priority for police and the courts,
but it's not,
not only your police launching more
raids against suspensory than ever
before,
but ridiculous charges for small scale
cannabis crimes are con continuing from
coast to coast.
So they,
they have a justice system that's so
broken that they can't even convict
people who raped miners a hundred times.
They can't take them to trial.
I mean there is there,
but it's that broken.
But they're still trying to fucking
catch people for a smoking weed and,
and just a rating dispensary's and Shit.
Like if I had to get a waste of fucking
time,
if I had to guess,
I would say it's some sort of
compartmentalism and that like the drug
people aren't,
they don't go after the other crimes and
they don't have to do with it,
you know?
And then there's a legal system that's
backed up,
but to put more people into the legal
system,
just because you have to somehow or
another justify the position that you're
in a cop of,
of a dea cop,
whatever they're called up there,
that's fucking crazy.
You got a broken system.
You have,
uh,
you're,
you're preying on people.
You're locking people up.
Yeah.
You mean if you,
if you want to impress us then convict
that fucking a rapist.
Don't,
yeah.
Don't fucking,
uh,
prosecute people who are smoking weed
for sure.
And by the way,
what you're doing right now seems like a
crime.
You're,
you're locking people up in a cage for a
plant that everybody on the planet knows
is not bad for you.
So if you just decide that because of
some fucking bullshit thing that's
written on paper,
that you should be able to go against
all the science that's available today.
All the common sense and the will of the
people.
And you should be able to go into
people's houses,
going to people's businesses,
arrest them,
take all their money,
take all their pot.
That's a crime.
That sounds like a crime.
It sounds like you're using your
position and you're using it to just
mark one up on the scoreboard.
You know,
we got some convictions today.
Good solid ones.
Bunch of dopers caught us.
A bunch of dopers had to let that crazy
pedophile go,
but we got all the dopay.
It dopers real scourge of society to a
hundred kids.
But you know what?
He didn't,
he didn't fuck them over by giving him
pot.
Yeah.
Casey wasn't smoking no weed.
It's those kids are going to remember
what he did to them.
It's not going to damage their memory.
Yeah,
I remember it.
So you remember it explicitly?
Jesus Christ.
It's just,
I can't believe that in this day and age
that shit is still going on.
It just seems like,
and Canada,
I thought with this Trudeau guy was
going to be more progressive than ever,
which Canadians are complaining about it
like crazy and you know,
I've had Jordan Peterson on the podcast
and he hates what's going on now with
this push towards being as open minded
as possible with all these accepting of
the gender pronouns and that you're
going to have to start putting people,
uh,
you're going to have to start processing
cases through the human rights council
because if you don't use a person's
proper gender pronoun,
it could literally be considered a
crime.
Like I think all that stuff on the left
when it goes way far,
it gets really crazy,
but it's probably a good thing to
balance out the stuff on the right and
people figure out some sort of
comfortable medium that he's not being
that at all.
He's not,
if you,
if the president is allowing this to go
on,
he's not being this progressive
president.
He's just not,
if he's only going to be progressive
towards Trans Gender Pronouns and
whatever other ridiculous laws that
they're swamped with.
This is,
this is just a terrible precedent to
set.
Allowing them to lock people up for pot
in 2017 is a fucking criminal waste of
resources,
a criminal waste of manpower,
uh,
criminal,
criminal intrusion on the freedom of
those people that you're locking up a
criminal on the disruption that you're
putting into their lives and the money
that you're taking away from them for,
for trading out your economy as well.
Yes.
And fucking your economy up and these
people were trading in something that is
very valuable to the community and to
the human beings that consume it.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm a,
I consider myself probably more liberal
than I am conservative,
but when I see the priorities of
liberals being identity,
politics,
shit,
gender pronouns and stuff,
and then so much of the real issues like
just get ignored like this.
Yeah.
Uh,
that makes me hesitant to even say like,
I'm a liberal or I'm more left wing and
right wing or whatever because I'm just
like,
you're,
your priorities are totally fucked.
They're totally out of order.
Uh,
you know,
apparently in Canada they're fighting
all these fucking politically correct
identity politics battles,
but they can't deal with the pot issue.
They're gonna their police raids against
pot dispensaries are actually up and
they're trying to charge people with
petty fucking weed,
smoking crimes.
And this is a thing that people always
go on about.
Like it's because it's pot,
it seems like it's not a big issue.
It's like it's not,
we've got bigger fish to fry.
Yeah.
When you look at Tj,
okay.
I don't know if you've been paying
attention to the stock market.
Okay.
Dj,
you know what the war in Afghanistan,
Tj,
yeah.
Okay,
we've got problems.
Real problems.
I was fucking pop thing.
You got damn potheads if it's off for
your pot,
oh,
what do I do?
Whatever.
But it's not that this what people have
to realize,
it's about personal freedom.
It's about a person telling you what you
can do and enforcing it to the point of
putting you in a fucking cage.
And that thing,
which had been an accepted part of
civilization for thousands of years and
is today accepted.
It's an accepted part of civilization,
civilization right now.
But there's just these people that don't
engage in it,
that don't understand it,
and that feel like they have the right
to go and lock people up for it.
You know,
when the trump administration started
signaling that they were going to,
uh,
take on weed or that they were thinking
about it,
at least that it was on the table,
like stupid at that point,
I was,
I made a video where I was,
I was basically,
it was like making all the cases why
this is terrible.
This is a bad idea.
Uh,
you know,
the,
I made the economics argument,
I made the personal freedom argument.
Um,
I may,
I,
you know,
I pointed out the tremendous amount of
revenue this is generating for the
states that have legalized it.
And a huge part of the response was just
like,
yeah,
oh yeah,
of course.
He goes after trump when trump goes
after his precious weed,
when he cares.
That's the only thing that got them to
care.
It's like fucking junkie.
I made fucking so many cogent arguments
that hold water about the economic and
personal liberty ramifications of
something like this.
And all you want to focus on is my
personal usage of this fucking
substance.
It's bullshit.
You Bet.
It's a good thing to talk about cause
it'll get you talking about it like
right now.
It'll get ya.
It'll poke coucher they know because
they know that people like you and I
really do enjoy our marijuana.
And when you tried to take away the pot,
we really do get upset.
Yeah.
I mean it was like kind of the like I
was kind of like on the give trump a
chance bandwagon until they started
signaling this stuff.
So that's why it really why I got shit.
It's a very,
very foolish thing to try to step in in
2017 with all the signs and all the
information and the public opinion and
to say that marijuana is something that
can get you locked up,
get you locked up,
but it's almost as bad as heroin.
He's so stupid.
That's a silly man.
That guy needs a pot Brownie more than
anything in this life.
He just needs a just a quarter.
Just give them a quarter.
Let him sit there and let him think
about his grandchildren and let them
think about fishing and let them think
about just napping in the sun and going
to meet the good Lord in a few years.
You don't have much time left,
motherfucker.
You want to ruin it for potheads.
You're barely alive.
Your hair's white,
your posture's bad,
and you're standing there lying.
You're lying on television about heroin
and pot being like really close.
That's a crazy person who doesn't know
what pot does.
You're talking about pot.
You obviously have no idea what it's
like.
It's like a person who's colorblind
describing some sort of a kaleidoscope.
You don't know what you're even talking
about.
Like for a guy like him,
if you want to have a person who's
talking about individual experiences,
they should have had,
like if you're talking about someone
who's talking about the effects of a
chemical and whether or not it should
be,
they should have had some sort of
experience with that chemical.
They should know what it's doing.
They should understand it,
especially if it's safe.
Something like marijuana.
So if you to talk about it and to have
these ridiculous,
you,
you can't,
you can invest one evening in a safe
environment.
They'll do it in a laboratory or a
hospital somewhere.
Pat Up the rooms and give you a pod
cookie and then put,
put pink Floyd's the wall on just
someone,
someone tell this fucking guy what it
really is.
Cause he's just talking out of his ass.
Yeah,
I mean,
uh,
I don't know if this is just apocryphal
or if they're,
this is an actual story,
but I remember there being something
about him saying that he thought the,
the KKK,
we're good guys until he found out they
smoked weed.
That was,
uh,
I think that was wrongly attributed to
him and that not only that,
there has been evidence that he's done
many things for civil rights.
I had read that too,
but I think that's,
it just might be the case of people
being overzealous and trying to paint a
demean.
You could find things,
I'm sure that you've said or that I've
started to take them completely out of
context.
You could paint a very different
opinion.
Definitely.
It's fucking very hard to form an
opinion of someone,
like a legitimate opinion if someone
without actually knowing them,
but you can have an opinion.
It's not that hard when they call and
say that,
uh,
that pod is nearly as dangerous as
heroin because then you did that person
at that point you're just like,
this person is either delusional or is
willfully deceptive.
Right.
And the important part about it is it's
not just a person.
It's a person with an extreme amount of
power.
Yeah.
It's a person,
a very dangerous position of enforcing
laws and you go,
okay,
well will you think that that's crazy.
That's not true.
Like,
I just drives me nuts because I think it
helps people.
I really don't.
I really do.
I really do think it's probably one of
the best elements in terms of uh,
a happy,
healthy society.
Staying grounded and being like a little
more kind.
I give,
I think it gives you a certain
percentage more of kindness.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
I've definitely seen it make people more
empathetic,
more tolerant towards one another.
I've seen people who have anxiety that
it helps.
it exacerbates their anxiety to the
edibles.
You're sure?
Like with a story I told about my
brother at the beginning of show,
but for the,
for the,
by and large,
I know a lot of people with like bad
anxiety who smoke weed and it makes them
feel better.
It makes them feel more comfortable in
social situations.
Um,
stuff like that too,
bro.
It makes you fucking talk about weed.
Yeah.
How come you guys keep talking about
wheat?
I get it.
You like weed enough already,
Bro.
I can read that.
No could read it in the comments there.
It's already there.
So much typing and stop talking about.
We get 'em.
I'm going to get,
I know tj reads these motherfucker.
I'm going to get them.
Don't talk about this.
Talk about this instead.
Suck it.
Feel the burn you motherfucker.
Well,
if you don't want us to talk about weed,
then tell jeff sessions to stop a
signaling.
He's going after it.
Jeff sessions needs to get high on
mushrooms to get that guy in a nice room
with Velvet curtains and gentle
Jefferson airplane from the 1960s real
low candlelight.
Put some black light posters on the
wall.
You don't need that.
You need,
and he's a black light.
I want it to just,
I want him to just sit there and stare
at a poster and watch it change shapes
and colors a bunch of times and like,
whoa.
Yeah.
You know what?
We do do black light posters areas,
but only only,
uh,
it's hard to imagine that fucker on
shrooms.
No,
it's not easy.
I see him wearing like an African garb.
Oh.
Like some sort of macrame beads around
his neck and shit,
but all the posters on the wall,
they're all that Bruce Lee poster from
enter the dragon with a blood across his
chest.
That's the greatest velvet poster of all
time.
That's the ultimate trailer Park Kung Fu
master poster.
Oh yeah.
I have that mother fucker up.
Have him watch that.
Watch all the things that turns into,
yeah,
poor old guy.
It's going to go to his grave without
trying mushrooms.
It's going to go to his grave thinking
we'd is as bad as heroin.
Maybe.
Uh,
maybe he took mushrooms and that was the
revelation he had.
Wow.
Marijuana is almost as bad as heroin is
so stupid because it doesn't kill you
and it's actually better for a lot of
people for pain than even heroin is.
Especially edible pot.
Edible pod is supposed to be really good
for people that have chronic pain,
stump,
massive producer of information,
but you can function on it like it is.
Especially physiologically.
You can function.
Like if you do something you already
know how to do and you're a,
you're high on pot,
especially edibles.
It doesn't have any like performance,
uh,
like decreasing elements to it.
It doesn't,
doesn't decrease your performance.
In fact,
a lot of people do it right before they
do Jujitsu cause they think it increases
their performance zone.
Where I've known people who get high
before they go work out because they're
like,
yeah,
you know,
it's going to keep me more focused and
especially if you're smoking like a
strong sativa strain,
it might give him a little energy burst.
Yeah.
You feel it man.
It feels like the fibers of your
muscles.
It's great.
Before Yoga.
Oh yeah.
I mean I,
I don't really do a lot of like physical
activities that much,
but like if I'm going to do like
stretching or something,
it's nice to be high and just like,
oh yeah.
Cause the best your muscles are way more
relaxed and stuff.
You're able to get your,
you have like flexibility.
You don't really have,
if you're just stone cold sober and all
your tension is still there and it feels
really good.
Like when you're stretching,
you're high,
it feels like,
oh you're supposed to be doing this.
You should do this more often dude.
Like you just have a better accounting
of what the signals your body sending
you.
Cause I think when you're,
when you're sober,
you know you can try to think about all
your different areas and tune into the
body and all the various points of
contact where the elbows meet the
forearm and think about all the muscle
tissue.
But you'd have to like really go through
it like step by step and be really
conscious of what you're doing when you
smoke pot.
It's just there.
I really enjoyed watching you fight with
a steven crowder about this by the way.
Oh he's a silly boy when it comes to
pot.
He's a silly boy overall.
I've had some
dealings with him.
The pop thing is interesting though
cause he didn't want to even debate it.
Like when we were pulling up the
information he thought it was being a
bully because we were pulling up things.
It showed a contrary to what he was
saying about car accidents.
I've since looked into it and the
American Automobile Association has some
statistics where they think that it's
increasing.
There's an increased number of people
that have marijuana in their system,
but the,
when they have the car accidents.
But the real problem with that is there
might be just as much of an increase in
those people smoking marijuana in that
area.
It might not be related to the accident.
Just because it's connected to the
accident doesn't mean it caused the
accident.
Car accident argument too.
Like,
you know,
you got to realize alcohol is causing
way more traffic accidents than,
than weed is.
That was what they were talking about.
There's,
in these places,
there's a lot of the places where people
were smoking pot.
There's a decrease,
a decrease in Dui fatalities.
There's a decrease in violent crimes.
There's quite a few different statistics
to look at,
but Colorado seems to be saying there's
a decrease in these car accidents and
in,
um,
Dui related incidents.
You know,
Steven crowder wanted to sue me too.
Why do you want to tell you he wanted to
see me?
We were on the same,
uh,
network for a while on Youtube and it
was called poly pop.
And the guy that was like my assigned,
I forget what the position is called,
the,
the fucking facilitator or whatever the
fuck he had the same one as I did.
And he told me,
you know,
uh,
that video you made about Steven crowder
and that,
that shit,
cause he got in a fight with some union
guy on footage and he was like,
I was attacked by this union thug and I
punched him.
I looked at the footage and I'm like,
wait a minute,
this guy gets up from the ground.
He's facing away from you.
It looked like someone pushed him from
behind because you see the whole video.
Yeah,
the beginning of it.
The guy threw a punch at him.
Well the guy was on the fucking ground.
Uh,
one point.
Yeah,
like,
but he's,
he,
you don't really see what happens with
them when you see,
you see the guy throw a punch at him
first.
I'm very familiar with the video.
I don't,
I don't know.
I looked at it,
I did the guys in his face.
Can we,
can we maybe see the guys in his face?
The guy comes close to him to get into
some sort of a grappling situation with
a guy like physically manhandled them.
I hold,
hold on.
This is on crowder's channel.
I want to see the,
there's like an un uh,
anelle edited version of this somewhere,
but it's,
you could see the full education when it
does happen.
It's taken even on crowder's channel.
Go scroll ahead a little bit.
I want to get to a,
I'll tell you what,
that's the guy that's the guy that gets
the guy that hits him.
Oh wait,
it's the guy's telling him to back the
fuck up.
So he puts his hands and hold on that,
that's the guy that fights and right
there,
the guy with the mustache,
which guy the mustache did and you see
this guy.
Okay.
You see that?
Like we don't,
there's like a missing piece of footage
there,
but in the footage I saw the,
you don't see that guy attack him first.
You see that guy get up from being on
the ground on his stomach.
I see what you're saying.
So something,
so when I was thinking is through the
guy that gets steven crowder pushed this
guy,
I don't know,
cause you don't,
there's no,
there's no footage on there.
But I,
I surmised based on what I looked at in
the footage that this guy was maybe
pushed and then got up and then started
wailing on crowder.
Hmm.
Interesting.
And I put that out there and here's the
interesting thing.
He said he was gonna sue me for what I
said about it.
Uh,
he then later went to court and a judge
looked at the footage and kind of came
to the same conclusion I did and said,
I don't think that this went down the
way you're saying based on the footage.
I see.
He lost that court case and then he had
to drop any sort of idea of a lawsuit
against me because the judge had already
ruled that the tape was bullshit.
Didn't really show what he thought it
said shed.
This is also instances where I
challenged him to debates back in the
day,
not recently,
but he would never acknowledge me.
I mean at one time he did send his like
little brother after me.
His brother?
Yeah.
Like I don't know if it was his younger
brother,
his older brother,
I think it was his little brother was
like,
you're a fucking faggot or whatever.
I'm like,
why won't your brother debate me?
Cause we were at the time on the Seine,
that word you're saying he sent them
after you physically?
No,
no,
just on twitter.
Oh,
okay.
You got to get best five.
Sorry.
Two dudes are looking at each other
outside of Barr.
He didn't come.
He didn't come and try to fucking fuck
me up or anything.
He just talking shit on twitter and they
talk shit on twitter.
You're sure that Steven's brother.
It was okay.
Yeah,
it was steven's brother.
But um,
but Stephen himself has never taught.
I made several videos about him.
Maybe not several like three.
Mm.
Uh,
but he's never confronted me.
Polyprop tried to get us to do a debate
at the time he wouldn't do it.
That seems when it's weird because like
he's mister like,
I'm going to go like,
he just trolled Janky yogurt the other
day,
you know,
it was,
I thought that was funny.
His,
his impression of Janky Yoga is fucking
fun.
It is pretty spot on.
The one that he did where he played Anna
and junk back and forth.
I didn't see that.
Oh fuck it.
Pull it up.
He'll let us use it.
But I like Steven crowder.
I do.
I really do.
I think he's a good guy.
I just,
you know,
he's like,
he's a little bit heavy on the right
wing.
He gets a little silly,
but he does some funny shit like this.
And when he crashed genx thing,
like with this,
the saddest thing was how Jank was
responding to it.
Like he,
he didn't have any sense of humor about
it.
Uh,
well Jank obviously takes himself very
seriously for some reason.
Do the research.
That's absolutely correct.
You will have it listed a Goc I agree
with you.
Cenk so much.
That's absolutely right.
When you use the f word,
you know,
it's real time.
So we have a bunch of people anyway.
You could see it online at one point.
He's porn bacon,
grease down his mouth.
I just thought it was funny.
It was pretty fine.
It's,
it's,
look,
dude,
I reached out to be able to make fun of
yourself.
I recently sat down,
uh,
we did this.
We went and watched a bunch of young
Turks videos so we could put out this
special drunken peasants versus the
young Turks.
A video.
We,
we shot about five hours of us watching
young Turks videos and just tearing them
apart.
And one
of the things I noticed is what Jank
we'll do [inaudible] and watch for this.
If you ever watch an his shit,
uh,
he'll have his panel say something
that's like super crazy left wing.
Like someone will say it,
like animal,
say it or one of the Steven O or
whatever.
Whoever got on Ben,
make a wits,
whatever.
They'll say something that's real far
left wing and then it'll cut to Janke
and Jank.
We'll have more of like a,
a moderate left wing opinion and then
it'll go back to them and they'll
immediately capitulate to Jank like,
oh yeah,
Jank you're,
you're,
what you're saying is way more sensible
than what I said a second ago.
And I just saw that pattern recurring
over and over and over again.
So I don't know if that's like by design
or if they're just,
they feel like the need to capitulate to
him because there they'd be scared of
him or something,
you know,
or uh,
or what it was definitely a lot of
emotion.
What's going on there too.
There's a lot of emotion in the way they
describe things and some people I think
at least initially connected to that,
but then they see where it gets
problematic.
If you're dealing with any like really
serious issue and you want to debate
just the facts like and have your ducks
in a row,
the wool,
the wool over my eyes was the Harris
debate because think most people,
exactly.
That was like the first like major chink
in the chank ugur armor.
I never know how to pronounce his first
name.
So when you said it that way,
I was like you,
you kind of think it's been changing
Cenk in the Jank you've Cenk in the
Jank.
Yeah,
there we go.
I think he's a good guy.
I liked talking to him too.
I just think people handle certain types
of confrontation and disagreements.
Um,
and they don't handle the best way they
could.
And then those things escalate and they
compound and then it becomes who you are
and then you defending who you are and
then you're always trying to argue with
people about who you are and what you've
done.
And like that's when you're gone.
Yeah.
It's when you're over the top,
it's like we've done that,
we've done that and we've done this,
we've done that.
Like,
Hey,
you're talking about shit that's
happening in the world.
That's all you're doing.
That's all any of us are doing.
That's all anybody's doing it.
Unless you're out there digging wells in
the Congo with Justin wren,
what you're doing is you're talking
about shit.
So if you got a bunch of people
listening to you talk about shit,
it's just talking about shit.
The end of the day you don't get any
extra points because more people are
listening or more people are watching.
Your point isn't more valid.
Your point still has to stand up in the
marketplace of ideas.
Yeah.
And yours is just as valid as his is
just as valid as mine.
It just,
if the delivery system is a bigger
delivery system,
it doesn't mean that like everybody has
to stop.
I'd take you into account because you've
had more success in this market.
That's a crazy way of looking at shit.
Sure.
And when him and Alex Jones battle back
and forth between who gets the most
viewers and who has the model like,
Holy Shit,
this is ridiculous.
Like what,
when did you see when Alex went onto the
stage at south by southwest?
Is that what it was south by southwest?
I think so,
yeah.
Last year.
It's hilarious.
Oh yeah.
That was the,
was one of the greatest,
uh,
trollings of all time.
But it,
jen got so mad.
I was furious.
And then dumb ass that little,
they oppose Saudi Arabia,
little weasel,
Jimmy Dore spitting on that.
So unfortunately Alex Jones did.
You know,
it's unfortunate that Guy Jimmy Dore
does some good stuff.
Yeah,
I've seen some of his stuff too.
This is a really good to put some really
good videos up.
He,
he's done some really good work.
Yeah.
I can't keep them.
I don't really care for him.
But um,
but,
but you recognize that some of this
stuff's really good,
right?
I've never seen this stuff.
That's good.
And maybe,
maybe,
maybe it's out there.
I haven't seen it.
I've seen it makes some good points.
Very good points.
Uh,
you know,
he,
when he was covering the whole Milo
thing,
he played a very deceptive version of
the Milo clip and he credited us
basically as a podcast.
And one that's talked about us is like,
we're doing this podcast from a basement
somewhere or something.
Meanwhile,
isn't it funny that a podcast like
yours,
which gets hundreds of thousands of
downloads,
I'm sure,
right?
Like you,
if it was more than that,
he would have to say the name of the
podcast.
Right.
Like if he was,
he was on the Adam Carolla show,
he would say the Adam Carolla show.
Sure.
Cause it's yours.
Even though he knows what it's like,
like I'm not going to give these guys
now.
And you know,
a lot of the media did that to us.
I was,
I was a,
there was like transcripts of the Milo
episode where it was like,
and then unknown host said this,
it's like,
fuck you,
I'm not in a bunker whites.
You guys can't just look it up.
Aren't you supposed to be like
journalists?
Can't you figure out what the fuck the
podcast was?
And I saw ones that attributed,
um,
stuff to me,
but then had stuff of yours where they
didn't even,
I didn't even know that you guys had him
on.
I thought that all the shit was coming
from my podcast because I got a text
message from my friend Chris Mcguire
informing me of all of it.
And so I went and I said,
well,
this isn't even my podcast.
And then I realized like,
oh,
he was on your podcast too.
And they combined the two different
things.
I even saw people say like,
he was on Joe Rogan's drunken peasants
podcast.
It's like,
wow,
people are supposed to trust you for
fucking information.
You're supposed to be a fucking credible
source.
You can't even get this basic shit.
Right.
So the media is a fucking joke.
Well,
the media now is,
it's total fucking joke.
He's like a few places we could still
trust.
Like where?
Um,
I'm hoping you were on the answer
because you know what?
People come to me all the time and
they're like,
Tj,
what news media outlet do you trust?
I'm like,
none of them.
I don't trust a single God damn fucking
thing.
Any of these institutions have to say
whatever Megan Kelly has to say.
I'm listening.
I'm Megan,
I'm in.
Hey again.
You're right about everything,
man.
It a lot.
That's what I like.
Like ice princesses.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
Like a main like Amina and smart,
really?
Not really.
No.
I'm like,
no,
but I'm fascinated by people who must,
you know,
some people,
they're perfect structure,
perfect bone structure,
steely blue eyes and peck will be
dressed,
talking about guns and the war and crime
and poverty and pot and prison.
We'll be right back.
You know the fucking bitch I really
hated back in the day was a nancy grace.
Oh,
she's the worst.
She's hideous.
Stole the worst.
She's horrible.
And like that,
that moral indignation that she has over
everything.
Like everything is always like,
yeah,
oh my God,
I cannot believe.
You know.
I hate that.
I hope that constant,
I'm indignant about everything in the
world and I'm this great moral judge
here to fucking tell people what's
really what another dead baby in
Florida.
Oh,
she's a monster.
Remember when she went up to those Duke
Lacrosse kids?
Yep.
The fake rape case and then never
apologized.
Now why would she?
She's perfect.
In fact,
she's probably still thinks those kids
did it.
Imagine that.
Imagine,
imagine being those kids and go home.
What in the fuck we didn't do that.
Oh,
Nancy grace.
Show up.
That's not the truth.
Those boys are terrible.
She's made her entire career off of like
exploiting the worst human beings and
their worst case scenarios and then
putting it on tv and getting everybody
outraged.
Yup.
[inaudible] machine hot mom.
She was the one who was chasing that
lady down that killed her kid.
Casey Anthony.
Remember that?
That was,
that was her big bloodhound moment.
Nancy Grace Review renews her criticism
of Taught Mom.
Who the fuck is Tottenham renewing?
She's that lady that killed her kid.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
so it's Casey and Casey Anthony.
I didn't,
I've never heard her called tot mom
before.
Yeah,
that's who she calls her or taught mom.
I tried to avoid experiencing Nancy
grace on any level.
Did you ever see her debate with two
chains?
Now they debated about pot,
two chainz and Nancy grace.
We're debating about pod on TV.
It was the most ridiculous shit ever.
Two chains and that have actually seen
that.
Now that you mention it,
why?
Why they let two Chainz do it?
Cause she probably thought he was a soft
target that she could just row
steamrolled in.
Oh yeah.
If you're going to do that with her,
you'd need to be in the room too.
You can't be on that split screen.
They talk over.
You could barely hear them.
This delay,
it's confusing.
They know what the fuck they're doing.
They'll split,
scream.
Things are weird.
You have something in your ear and
they're talking to them.
You don't see them.
You're staring right at camera,
dude.
Yeah.
Don't,
when I wasn't looking at them and I was
on CNN,
like not only that,
but like I was in a huge gigantic room
and the camera was like 30 feet away,
so I'm looking at this camera that's
like in the distance,
like talking and nothing it,
there's a fucking earpiece in my ear
that keeps falling out and it's designed
that way,
man.
It's designed to,
well,
first of all for convenience for them,
for the people that are filming.
Yeah,
but also like the best way to get a good
reaction out of a,
the guest is put the guests under
pressure,
put them on a press button and then some
weird situation and have some smooth
talking cukor Tucker Carlson type
character.
Oh Dude.
Tucker Tucker,
I'm really disappointed he didn't stick
with the bow tie.
I was hoping I am too,
but you know what?
He seems like his ratings or better.
So maybe the bow tie this fucking lot.
But like I remember like,
I love how every fucking answer anyone
gives to him on his show.
He always does this like,
yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah,
yeah.
Always has this like perplexed.
Like what,
yeah,
he's an interesting guy.
He's sort of taking this middleman
republican approach,
sort of the middle,
you know,
like more reasonable,
more and more towards the middle will
be,
can I understand your position?
Like,
let me,
let me go over your position one more
time please.
Like he's,
he's,
he's sort of semi mocking,
but clearly on the right.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
the,
the great thing too is that he's kind of
brought that,
um,
that Internet strain of conservatism
over to Fox News.
Cause like,
you know,
Bill O'reilly and Sean Hannity,
they're not tapped into that shit.
Right,
right.
Bill Tucker is,
yeah.
And it's clear.
Right,
right,
right.
So He's,
he's,
he's basically appealing to,
uh,
probably a younger conservative
demographic.
I would imagine than than Hannity and a
o'reilly get,
he's appealing to the people that have
seen one too many Alex Jones videos
where they've gotten to that one point
that like,
I can't do this anymore.
And then they go over to Tucker.
So what was it,
what was it like having him having him
on here by the way,
Alex Jones,
it was a dream come true.
Like sit and face to face and listen to
him talk.
Well,
I've been friends with them for a long
time,
right on that guy since 1999 I think it
was fun.
It was fun for me,
but it was also something like for the
longest time people thought I was
avoiding having him on for some reason
and he kept saying,
well,
I tried to get ahold of Joe Rogan every
month,
Tom and Tom,
but he blows me off.
He was always texting the wrong number.
He's always like,
he didn't get worried.
Get Ahold of me that day.
And I'm like,
dude,
I already have a podcast schedule.
I can't do it today.
Well,
I'll be back soon.
One of my bag.
We'll figure it out.
And then he would go on.
I show Joe Rogan's been avoiding me.
I've been trying to get in there to give
out this information is very important.
Maybe scared,
maybe he's been threatened.
The government threatened him.
He won't open up about bigfoot.
I believe Joe Rogan did experience big
foot.
He saw he was there in the woods.
Now Alex doesn't really believe in big
foot.
I guess.
Who knows what he's got fries.
I know he believed.
He seems to believe in demons these
days.
Oh yeah.
Well they are demons.
They're all,
they're all demons from hell.
All of them.
They're damned.
I'm sorry.
And if you see red thing where he
doesn't eat,
you apologize.
The apology,
the apology compilation.
Excuse me.
It's amazing.
I will stop your head.
Excuse me.
I've got to,
that's just a Christian family show.
It's like,
what the hell?
I am a Christian and I apologize.
He's just such a fucking awesome guy to
me.
He's awesome.
He's,
he's like a boundless source of
entertainment.
And if you knew
him,
man,
like if you,
me and him went out,
we went to a bar,
we had a couple of drinks,
we would have a great fucking time.
I'm telling you,
he's a really nice guy.
He's a real nice guy.
And he would start telling you,
well,
the Barium,
they'd been putting bury him in the
water and you're like,
what?
You want another beer?
Like it's,
it's,
I'm telling you he's a great guy,
but I understand that people are upset
that he has the president's ear and
maybe the president is like me.
Maybe the president just thinks he's
awesome.
Listen to crazy stories.
I'm just like,
yeah,
Berryman.
The water sounds great.
Inner dimensional child molesters are
coming in through the cigarette,
smoke cigarettes with the 599 chemicals
are designed to let the gates of hell
come loose.
Knit interdimensional child molesters
come in and he just will go on and on
and on.
I love the interdimensional child
molester thing because it's like they
have interdimensional travel
capabilities and they're like immediate
thing.
Like what do we use this for?
I know what's will kids will rape kids
and other dimensions,
you know,
like what?
Well there always is that really the
best application of that fucking
technology.
They're always like the archetypes of
like when you get into the really hard
core conspiracy theorists,
the heart,
the archetypes are always like very
satanic.
The archetypes are always like a
eugenics.
Like they want to kill off a massive
amount of the population.
Um,
engineering a master race,
like,
oh,
there's all like keeping all the
medicine and the resources for the
elites killing off everyone else.
Uh,
preparing to get off this planet because
they know it's doom cause Nibiru who's
coming?
It's all this like apocalyptic shit.
It's really fascinating because it's
like so much of it revolves around
these,
these like,
and then they sell supplements and
survival kits.
Well that's what he does.
Nobody sells a better than Jim Baker.
He sells them his furniture.
He seen that video.
He's selling his toilets.
Dude.
Have you seen him sell it?
Like,
you know,
after he says after the bonus bucket is
empty,
you can use it as a toilet.
Oh,
so like when you're out there in the
woods.
Yeah.
You know the modern plumbing after the
apocalypse,
people don't even know how bad shit
smells.
Cause most of the time you don't really
smell it.
You smell it.
Water down,
plop logs.
When you,
when you take a shit in the woods,
that's when you really go,
oh Jesus Christ.
And at least then you're outside with
all that air and a nice stiff breeze.
But if you take a shit in a room,
in a bucket,
it's going to smell so horrible.
You will start gagging and throwing up.
You'll be so disgusted.
Not to mention you'd have to actually
eat,
they're supposedly fucking five years
worth of disgusting macaroni and cheese
or mashed potato.
It was to actually get the bucket empty
enough to shit in it.
That's true.
So I mean like look at that as Jim
Beggar's bowl and look at all in any of
these fucking old fucks gonna live long
enough to even,
they are,
who cares if they survive the
apocalypse?
They're fucking probably not even going
to survive this demo for fuck's sake.
Well you don't know is we are all
battening down the hatches and waiting
for Jesus's return.
Okay.
The slop that was in the bucket and the
slap,
they're putting their mouths is not the
same.
Oh,
you think there's different?
It does not the same.
There's just
like a rice pudding maybe.
It looks like a fine risotto.
It's a risk Soto.
Yeah.
Oh,
look at those poor people in the
audience.
Forget about being so fucking stupid
that you watch it on tv because it's
just on.
But imagine being so fucking stupid.
Like you said,
go to see the chairman today and take
the bus into the town to go and sit in
the audience and this in the past you're
doomed.
I think they offer them free food.
I think they tell him like,
yeah,
you get a free meal if you come in here.
That's all they need.
A free meal.
They're like,
Ooh,
sweet.
Free food.
All they probably excited to be on
television as well.
That's true.
Books.
They have books open.
Pack that up.
Look,
but don't they have like books in their
hands?
Probably those same books you see on the
stage.
Probably just passing them out.
Get them to try to fucking buy this
bonus bucket.
Shit.
Hey look,
we've got like notes.
People are taking notes.
This is important stuff.
What's important?
Well,
okay,
if vile eat one played that Rojo would
die.
I could be underground for 50 years.
I've got willpower.
I got a wind shirt on.
Look at these fucking people.
They're taking notes.
Like,
this is like really important stuff that
Jim Baker's talking about.
I just loved this guy.
Keeps on keeping on.
Oh yeah.
He's like the energizer bunny dude.
Yeah.
No one's talking to Jessica Hahn these
days.
Okay.
Nobody even cares about her anymore.
I look at him.
He looks smooth as fuck.
He's got that sleek white hair.
I got a cute little beard.
Look at him.
He's thin.
It looks healthy.
Passionate.
Yeah.
He's got the drive.
He's got the energy.
It's got this hot little piece of ass
behind him in the green shirt.
Yeah.
Look at her.
It's fun.
Actually.
If you watch this shit,
sometimes you'll see them like,
uh,
openly argue on the show.
But like,
it'll be like very like,
uh,
restrained.
Like I remember one time he was,
he was like talking about marijuana or
something and he's like,
you used to smoke marijuana in your
college days didn't change.
She's like,
Oh yeah.
And then,
you know,
just picture a smoking pot and taking
tech like a champ.
Oh yeah.
Right.
I mean,
uh,
she,
she does have that vibe,
doesn't she?
For sure on strong sure.
Trophy wife vibe going on.
Yeah.
Especially for someone that guy's age.
Well,
we found out from the Jessica Hahn days,
that dude was a party.
He liked to party.
That's his deal.
He likes to talk about the Lord and he
may be even believes it,
but after that she has done woo,
let's parties down to fuck.
Yeah.
That's what Christianity Christianity's
all about.
Forgiveness.
Y'All.
Yeah.
Listen man,
I'm just get forgiven the next day.
That's a beautiful thing.
He's got a good market.
He's got it locked in.
Who's that?
Joel Olsteen guys that his name?
Yeah.
Joel Olsteen.
That guy.
He does arenas,
man.
Oh,
that guy.
Just the same place where we do the UFC.
He was coming the next day or the next
week.
I was like,
that's crazy.
He fills the fucking arena.
Is that like prosperity doctrines shill?
Look at homeless people.
Maybe I'm in the wrong business.
Yeah.
I've thought about it before.
I'm like,
man,
how much do I have to know about Jesus?
Talk about him on stage.
Not a whole lot.
I was thinking like,
oh,
I could fucking spinned this yarn about
like I used to be this,
uh,
youtube atheists.
Yeah,
dude,
you should totally do that.
And now all deemed and I found Jesus and
Oh yeah,
I'll just,
I'll do it all nice and conservative and
shit and,
and I'll be like,
yeah,
I found Jesus turned my life around.
I was depressed.
We'll stop right there.
Stop right there.
And no one's going to believe you.
Change your fucking accent to a mocking
southern accent.
You know,
obviously you can't do that for you,
but let's,
let's just run through how we would have
you do it.
Okay.
If we're going to reinvent you,
look,
let's just say the company,
the country,
rather,
move so far into conservatism.
That is dangerous.
Being an atheist is dangerous,
being a liberal and you've got a certain
amount of financial requirements.
Now you've got a mortgage,
you know,
maybe you got a car payment.
You're like,
well fuck man,
I need to get this money to keep coming
in.
I know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to reinvent myself and
there'll be a performance art piece I do
for a few years or become a
conservative.
Come conservative Christian.
Yeah.
Give my life over to Jesus.
What would be the event that we would
need to talk about?
Like we'd have to describe an event that
motivated you to make the big chain.
Oh Shit.
It had to be something that I could,
I could fake easily,
but it seems credible and believable.
Like maybe a little baby heart attack.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
You're a little overweight.
I guess it'd be like I had my heart
attack and uh,
I can't even fucking,
maybe I could spend some kind of like
near death yarn or some shit.
Yeah.
Look,
you blacked out.
Like something happened yet to like a
little minor heart attack and your legs
stop working.
You blacked out.
And I saw it was in a tunnel and I saw
the lights and I felt like a presence
and an energy love that I'd never
experienced before.
What did,
what did,
what was your initial reaction to this
love and this experience?
Oh,
um hmm.
I think,
uh,
she was,
Lord,
should we go the hell route?
Should we go?
Like I saw,
you know,
I was cast out of this place and I went
to hell.
Or is that too over the top?
Here's my take on things.
Yeah.
This is what I believe.
I believe you're allowed to talk about
God all day long,
but as soon as you talk about the devil,
only a select group of people are going
to hear you.
That's true.
If you talk about your cause more people
believe in God and believing in the
whole fuck.
Yeah.
Not only that,
it's culturally acceptable to describe a
belief in a higher power.
And if you don't even say God,
you get away with it.
Like for 90% of the people.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
All you have to do is say I'm spiritual,
I'm nondenominational,
but I'm spiritual.
And ultimately I believe in a higher
power.
I just think it's very possible that
some,
I,
I leave the option areas like the seven
planets fucking thing.
Like what's that?
They say?
Uh,
it's like a,
it's like a reincarnation trope where
you're like,
you go through like seven stages of,
of life where like the first year I
think humans are like second or third on
the list.
But eventually,
like in your seventh life,
you become like a being of a,
well,
I mean it's not necessarily your seventh
cause you're,
you're,
you're like repeatedly attempting you.
So you become like an enlightened being.
Yeah.
Like if you're,
if you're,
if you're a shitty human being,
you might get sent back or you might
just be a human being again,
but eventually you get reincarnated is
like an immortal being of the pure
enlightenment
and just did one with the cosmos and all
that shit.
I got Dalai Lama.
Yeah,
you could do like a,
like a,
you know,
can you put the pedal that new age shit,
right?
Because they've,
they like said it and I'm like seven
different planets too.
Like you go from one planet to the next
as you progress up the ladder of fucking
liars.
This all of us.
But what is this?
What religion is this one?
I don't know.
It's just some crazy shit I heard one
time,
but I could roll with that seven
planets.
Yeah.
You have seven times to re reinvent
yourself and like totally.
I'm totally,
I have my shit together now.
I'm 500 years old,
but I'm totally together.
Finally I can say I'm whole.
Nope.
Then you ascend.
Then you're saying you send to
enlightenment to the seventh planet
where you live out the rest of your
existence.
So in pure love and joy,
if we just had you talking on CNN again
and they would go,
well,
what,
what inspired you to make this decision
after all your years of atheism,
youtube videos to become a Christian and
now that you are a Christian,
are you going to take those videos down?
No,
I'm going to leave them up so people can
see that.
I really was this atheist.
I really did give credence to these
atheist beliefs,
but now I've,
I've just,
I've,
I've rejected that all and in fact I'm
going to go through all my old videos
and rebut them and show where I was
wrong and explain why I was wrong.
So stay tuned for that.
Oh,
genius.
I love it.
And you can also say,
you know what's really ironic is I did
Joe Rogan's podcast and we joked around
about this happening and then it did
happen.
And it's so crazy.
You just fucked this whole plan because
it's all,
it's all public.
No,
no,
it's not because it's your,
your belief in the Lord.
So powerful that despite the fact that
you talked about faking it,
you're going to talk about it in the
exact same way because it actually did
happen.
It's almost like God was like,
Oh,
you think you're so smart,
Tj?
Well,
I'll show you.
I'll show you and I'll have the exact
same scenario,
play itself out and I will show myself
to you and I will touch your heart.
Yeah,
there you got.
The Lord did.
He touched my heart,
tj.
Just a few,
a scant few years later.
How much my heart,
how much you think Joel Olsteen clears
in one day.
We can look,
you can look and his net worth some
probably scary.
And what's that's gotta be here.
Supposedly what it's worth.
56 million lives in a $10 million house.
It's a good little good little scan he's
got going.
That's probably more ag balling Hashtag
ball and for Jesus.
That's incredible.
Now,
how does one justify that?
We had this guy on will mccaskill who,
uh,
runs this organization called effective
altruism.
He donates all of his income above
$35,000 so he gets to $35,000.
He keeps that everything else he
donates.
Yeah.
That's like a real holy man.
And a lot of ways.
I mean,
he's just living laughable.
Olsteen $56 million net worth $10
million just comes home and his gold
underwear.
Well,
look,
he's kind of smart.
He's,
he's built prosperity into the his
doctrine.
Cause what he pedals is like,
if you,
if you're good and God loves you,
God wants you to be successful and
prosperous.
Right now there's nothing in Christian
doctrine actually back that up.
Like Christians are persecuted and God
does not give them an easy life.
They get crucified upside down and they
get persecuted by authorities and all
sorts of stuff.
But he's figured out some way to spin
it.
Like if you love God and God loves you,
that God wants you to be successful.
So basically his,
all his money in his houses and his
prosperity,
that's all that's,
God gave that to me and that's part of
my faith.
Yeah,
but you asked for it,
bitch,
you asked for money.
The people paid,
they paid to hear the word of God and
hearing it through you.
God didn't get involved at any point.
What happens if somebody really
charismatic who's really smart,
decides to play that as a scam?
I mean,
it's happened a bunch of time start
history,
but like someone is like a really good
actor.
Like Denzel Washington,
Denzel Washington becomes a religious
icon too.
Could you imagine if Denzel Washington
at a nowhere had some religious epiphany
or faked it and then decided to go on
television and and,
and had like a very powerful message for
people and then started making youtube
videos and then started preaching and
arenas.
People would,
oh my God,
you would leave there.
Your life would be changed.
Denzel Washington,
Denzel Washington from like training
day,
like the kind of fucking power that guy
can deliver.
If he could deliver a sermon like that,
Joel Olsteen would just jump off a
building.
He would watch that and go with the FEC
business and Joel Olsteen would be like
his opening act.
If an email is,
it would be like the shitty opening band
that no one cares about.
Yeah.
If you got like a real actor,
like a real powerful actor to go up
there and do it in a real,
I mean there's like,
like a guy like Leonardo Dicaprio,
like Leonardo Dicaprio.
It's a problem with Leo is he's too
handsome and he gets too much posey.
You're not going to take them seriously.
You just not,
he's just got too much money.
He's always bawling on all over the
world is on yachts with models.
Too much money.
I'm sorry.
But if we could get past that,
if somehow or another we could get past
that,
like if that guy has settled down,
he had a wife and he had a kid and then
he had some religious epiphany and then
he really got close to the Lord and he
was really like gathering up the
scripture and then he started fucking
preaching.
You really want this happen to you want,
I can sense it in you like,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Well I soon politics is for people that
suck at Showbiz.
Yeah.
It's for ugly people.
The Suck Showbiz and that's essentially
what religion is.
I mean it's like a four.
It's another form of show business.
Does it mean what you're doing is by
doing it that way.
The only way you do it that way is you
have to put on a performance.
If you've got to stand in front of all
those people and talk about what the
Lord does to me,
like whatever.
What do you have passion for it or not.
That is an orchestrated performance.
It's an art form.
Your design,
your riling sensibilities
up and stimulating their minds.
Fucking weird.
It's a fucking weird way to worship.
You know,
it's very weird.
You pay a bunch of money to get no arena
and some con man screams and yells about
the lord and pretends that he could read
people's minds and heal the sick.
Those motherfuckers that touch people
wiggle there.
There.
Oh,
your death.
I'll wiggle my finger in your ear and
now you can hear it's a miracle.
And then they're rushed off real quick.
You know,
like by deaf person or formerly deaf
person.
What's really creepy when the,
I forget which one,
which guy got busted with the earpiece
or the preacher.
They exposed to my James Randy.
That fucking set up that,
that the operation where you could hear
his wife talking to him and tell him,
no doubt people yell is healer guys as
Benny Hinn type dudes.
And I didn't destroy his career either.
He kept going,
why don't people aren't reading?
Just keep going.
Peter popoff was Peter popoff.
Peter popoff.
I didn't know who that guy was to so
many of them know.
It's just,
it's,
I guess that's the way they make a
living.
Yeah.
It's a nice little racket.
They got going.
We were talking about doing it for you.
I think you could do it though.
You can fucking nail.
You could do it.
Any of us could do it.
You could really do it.
I could really do it.
Yeah.
Cause I got the whole atheist angle.
I can play like I used to be this way,
but now I've seen the light,
the former amazing atheist.
Now the amazing Christian.
I can see the title now.
Yeah.
I have to get some,
uh,
like teeth.
Whitener and dude,
you get it.
Cut My hair a little bit.
Your hair short.
It'd be fine.
Cut the hair a little shorter.
Yeah.
Find yourself a nice Christian Gal.
Dress up in a nice,
that's,
it would be hot Christian Pussy.
That's what took you over to the top.
Oh yeah.
I can even tell.
Tell him that.
Like,
look,
I just noticed that the Christian Pussy
is just way higher caliber,
so it's way better.
They're freaks,
they're all suppressed and when you
finally get him alone,
they think Jesus isn't looking.
Yeah,
thank you.
And that's why I decided to convert.
Imagine if like it took a few years and
then you had made it,
look,
I'm just going to be real with y'all.
I converted because Christian Pussy is
the best pussy.
It's like it's not even close.
You know it.
Come on.
Why do we mind?
You got to believe in Jesus when you
just know.
I mean you know you fucking atheist
pussy or a pagan pussy or whatever and
you're like,
all right,
I guess this is okay,
but you hit that Christian pussy and you
just feel that the might of God touching
your cock is almost like Jesus himself
is giving you a hand job.
Can you imagine if there was a belief
system that changed the way your pussy
felt?
Like if,
if,
if you knew that the girl didn't believe
in Jesus when you had sex,
like oh it was all wishy washy down
there.
No structure.
Like,
like we were talking about this the
other day about wild pigs that when wild
pigs get loose,
like you take a domestic pig,
when they get loose,
their body morphs,
their snout grows,
the hair gets thicker,
their tusks role grow longer.
Imagine if like when a
woman really believes in Jesus,
if she really believed in God,
her pussy would just tighten down like a
fist and you would realize it when you,
when you were fucking,
they're like,
wow,
the Lord is inside of her.
This is a garage should come inside of
that cause I should make babies with her
because the Lord is inherent.
She really,
when the Lord Lord resides within this
con man,
we could maybe you could tell by having
sex with them.
Imagine that and the guys would cry.
Bill grew,
believed in the Lord,
whoever,
girl bereaved or girl I believe,
believed in the Lord.
I was out outsource where I was like,
just take him out dick and a bucket of
Jello.
There was enough and there's nothing.
There's no,
hey,
there's no hope.
There's no future.
And there's this guy holding his wife's
hand,
like a death grip.
She's got this Christian smile and her
eyes and you know,
our pussies,
a vice grip,
just up ball Milkin,
vice grip,
industrial suction power,
clamp down.
Imagine
there's already a lot more Christians.
Yes.
You know,
that would be something that would be
something that would uh,
would definitely get people on the side
of Christianity.
That's one of the weird things about
Islam.
This is only the more radical sex of it.
And the more,
the deeper that people get into it when
they want to cover up the entire woman,
like cover everything came and see her,
can't even see her when she goes out,
cover it up.
And the,
the idea is like if you don't cover up,
then you know,
men are just going to be like totally
rape crazy.
Like,
oh my God,
they must,
they must really like the fuck.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
they,
you know,
like the,
the,
I don't know how,
how,
how true statistically it is.
But you know,
they say that like they're,
the rape is a big problem when they go
to these western countries,
these refugees and shit.
Oh they're probably not used to seeing
all these little short,
short like God,
it's like a fucking buffet,
a pussy around here.
Don't you think that any country that
has been around for as long,
like any part of the world really we're
civilization has existed in [inaudible]
for a long,
long,
long time.
It's very difficult to get those people
off their old ways.
You know,
and when you're dealing with a place
like the Middle East,
Iraq is the oldest with,
they think that like sue mayor,
which is where our rack is as far as we
know,
that's the oldest civilization we're
currently totally aware of.
Right?
6,000 years ago there was people living
in there and they had mathematics.
They had,
agriculture has really advanced
civilization for the time and the,
the people that are there today in a lot
of ways.
I mean there's people who have come in
and people have left.
But a lot of the fucking energy and the
ideas that culture are still in some way
connected to this 6,000 year old
culture.
We're still kinda fucked in this country
cause we're connected to,
the puritans were connected to the
pilgrims that landed.
I mean all these people that came over
here seeking religious freedom and they
were super religious and super
puritanical and their beliefs,
remember it wasn't just the puritans
were saying it was,
it's,
it was kinda like the puritans were
sent.
Well
the puritans came here to escape
religious persecution and then a lot of
the dregs of their society were sent
here.
Like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Go over there.
Yep,
go colonize the new world forum,
a new life for yourself there.
That's my family.
Well,
you know,
that's what I'm saying like,
but if you really look at it,
that's like the flip side.
I mean,
you can kind of even look at America
today and still see like,
oh,
here's the pure,
here's where the puritan element comes
in and here's where the degenerate scum
fuck element comes in,
and then you got America,
right,
right.
Yeah.
It's a look.
Anytime you start a fresh country,
it's a God damn gamble and a bunch of
people are going to come over here and
you're not going to get the best stuff.
But look at Australia.
Australia was started as a prison
colony.
It's one of my favorite places to visit.
The people were fantastic.
Never been there.
Oh Man,
you'd love it.
Fucking Melbourne is amazing.
It's amazing.
One of the best cities I've ever been
to.
The people are so cool.
They're like,
it's like a cool San Francisco type vibe
with a weird accent.
Not Weird to them.
Fucking nicest people in the world.
There's so few of them.
They have it so much better over there
because there's as many as there is in
the La area and their entire fucking
country.
Now what?
What I do?
That's a lot of fucking people,
man.
Oh you just like,
we're like,
I just,
cause I'm thinking about that,
like how ridiculously overpopulated we
are.
Oh yeah,
the second I land in La like you go
watch,
there's like a weird vibe instantly.
Like I just feel like way more guarded
here and stuff cause I,
there's like a sense of like,
like a faint whiff of like violence
that's always in the air here.
You can just feel like the tensions that
exist.
And I noticed people are like,
a lot of people aren't here a super
apologetic all the time for like the
slightest thing.
And I think it's just cause they all
feel it.
Like there's like kind of a powder keg
here that could just explode at anytime.
Or maybe they're just polite.
They're not like,
what are people that are super
apologetic about what look like I was
when I went,
first thing happened to me when I walked
out of the airport was this guy,
he's,
he's doing a suitcase and he hits my
foot with it and he says he's sorry.
He's like,
oh I'm so sorry.
But he keeps pulling it like,
you know,
so he's not really changing what he's
doing.
He's just given me an apology for it so
I won't get mad about it basically.
Oh,
I see.
So he didn't stop what he's doing and
readjust and try to not hit your foot?
Yeah,
I mean I just got out of the way at that
point,
but,
but you know,
it's,
it's like people around here,
they almost,
they tried to like,
uh,
diffused a sorry over things to diffuse
any possible like,
well if I say sorry,
then people won't be as pissed and
everyone's kind of stepping on each
other's toes here because it's so
crowded.
There's so many fucking people,
there's so many different cultures
trying to coexist,
you know,
in one place,
like even,
you know,
from Seattle and shit,
like the area I live in has got like a
lot of Asians there and stuff,
but like you don't really feel that
sense of like the clash going on or like
there's tensions between these different
groups of people because the attitude
that they have like in the northwest,
uh,
at least the parts of it I live in and
just kind of like,
people just can't really,
don't give a shit about each other.
And there's sort of like an air of like
detached,
like,
yeah,
you know,
I'll be somewhat friendly and shit,
but we're not all going to fucking,
we're not going to exchange all these
niceties and shit in his very brusque
attitude and people are to speak the
entire area.
Yes.
You view this spokesperson.
I am their spokesperson in Seattle to be
very friendly.
Well,
I don't live exactly in Seattle.
So maybe you're in the area where people
go to escape the friendliness of
Seattle,
maybe.
So.
Maybe I am.
Well,
I mean,
I,
there's a lot,
like I said,
there's a lot of Asians there.
They tend to be brusque.
I feel like racism here comes,
Oh yeah.
Especially against Eskimos.
I don't fucking put up with that in you.
Which shit?
Yeah,
I'd like Pacific northwest.
I think it's a,
you're,
there's a neat,
unique connection with nature when you
get rained on all the time and
everything's green is fuck.
Oh yeah.
I think you guys have a better
connection with nature.
Like A,
I have some friends that live in Ballard
and we went to,
um,
there's a park over there,
you know,
and they have kids that are my kids'
age.
We all went to the park and we were
hanging out there and we're like,
God damn,
everything is so green.
It was like,
you guys are not just used to this.
Like this is like normal for you.
Right?
Yeah.
And we will.
And,
and,
and it was a rare day where it was like
super sunny and warm and it was like,
okay,
if this was like this all the time,
do you know this place would be so
fucking crowded?
Like your,
your relationship that you have with
nature is what keeps people away.
But it also enhances,
in my opinion,
the way the people that live there look
at things.
I think they're more grounded.
Yeah.
Like I,
I'm not really one who like,
uh,
focuses a lot on like the physical
beauty of an area.
But like I love just driving through
like over a bridge or something in,
uh,
in,
in the Seattle area and just seeing all
the fucking hills and all the entries
and all the water and everything just
looks really like serene and picturesque
and beautiful even though you know,
there's a shit ton of people there.
Yeah,
there's a giant potluck,
but like in la it's like there's the,
the sun and everything,
but you just,
it just looks like a fucking,
when you fly in la,
that's just like a big grid of fucking
lights and shit.
There's not much of a of nature left for
you to be like,
ah,
well this is a flat patch of desert.
They slapped all these stupid buildings
up on.
If it wasn't for this,
it'd be like chaparral and fucking
tumbleweeds and dirt.
But what Seattle also has is you guys
have the ocean and the mountains all
just jammed up on top of you too.
Like you can get to mount rainier from
Seattle and what is it like 70 minutes,
something like that.
I think it might be a little longer,
but maybe an hour and a half,
two hours at the most because we were,
we were up there,
big foot squash and we were squashing me
and Duncan trussell and we drove down
from there,
from Mount Rainier to a hotel in,
you know,
in the mainland and the regular area.
So it was close enough that like within
two hours or whatever it was,
we could be in the middle of this
incredible rain forest and then go right
back down then.
And you're looking at the ocean right
there too.
It's just so fucking vibrant.
I look at it,
it's like where I live,
I'm like,
I feel like I'm in the middle of
the fucking woods are,
but I can drive five minutes and be in,
in the downtown area.
Right.
It's just crazy.
Yeah,
it is crazy.
You can't really get that.
Uh,
in,
in La.
No.
And you have a good amount of people up
there too.
Like what is Seattle's population,
like 5 million or something of the
entire metropolitan area.
Something like that.
I know off hand,
but find out what it is.
Young Jamie,
I'm going to guess it's like 5 million,
which I think you should put a cap on.
Don't let anybody move to me will die
dude.
Like even when I moved there,
less than 5 million.
How many city says it's only 650,000 you
got to look at the Seattle metropolitan
area though.
That's a good number though.
650,000 that's beautiful.
But even when I moved there,
like when I told people just went 7
million,
703.7 so that ain't shit.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
You know,
but like even when I moved there,
like people are already kind of like,
I could sense like people being like,
Eh,
more people and people always do that
though,
man.
Yeah.
They're like,
no,
we're good.
It's just like you said,
you know,
like,
let's try to try to stop anyone new from
coming.
Greedy fucks.
It's like,
fuck you.
You've got a great spot.
If you wanted to go more hippy though,
would you go portland?
Uh,
no.
No.
I don't know.
I've never really been to portland sweet
spot.
I'm actually planning on going to
Portland to see,
you're a concert you're doing there.
Yeah.
20th of February.
Don't.
By 20th of April.
You didn't buy tickets,
did you?
I don't know.
I'll hook it up.
Yeah,
I got a lot of people coming.
Okay.
How many people?
Uh,
six or seven.
I can make that happen.
All right,
cool.
But um,
that's bought is a,
portland to me is like,
um,
there's a few,
there's like a handful of places that I
would live outside of La,
Seattle,
Seattle for sure.
Portland for sure.
Denver,
Austin,
Texas.
And then it would get weird.
I get weird after that.
Everything else would get like,
man,
maybe I could do it,
but outside of Denver or boulder,
when I say Denver,
I'm really mean.
Colorado.
Like I could live in aspen too.
I love it.
I love when I was trying to escape Ohio,
like we all sat down and we were trying
to all come to a consensus about where
to move to and like a lot of those
places were considered like we,
we were tossing around Austin,
we were tossing around La,
we were tossing around Portland and
we're tossing around Seattle.
So it's kind of pretty similar places
where we would live.
Those are the only places cause I was
not happy living in Columbus,
Ohio.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of great people in
Columbus.
Sure.
But that winter can suck my dick.
Yeah,
that's,
we were done with it.
Fuck you.
Giant mountains of fucking snow just
piling on us.
I mean,
I mean Duncan trussell I'm texting him
every day.
Fuck New York City cause another
blizzard just hit,
you know,
and I'm like fuck you and fuck New York
because Duncan just moved there.
I'm like,
why'd you leave me bitch,
you leave.
You left me and went to a stupid spot
that's nose in the middle of Goddamn
March.
It's deep.
We're deep into March.
Right.
What is it like the 16th or something
15th Fuck Outta here.
Can't be snowing.
That's,
that's too late.
It's no more snow.
No,
no,
stop it.
It's not allowed to snow anymore.
Fuck this.
You get jammed in there for a couple of
days.
But even that,
like I think New York is a weird
combination of weather and extreme
population.
I think when you get that,
whether there could be,
there's good things like what Seattle
has is like a good amount of whether
like it gets rain but it only snow.
It was like a couple of days a year if
that,
like it only gets below actually a
pretty weirdly heavy snow storm.
Um,
this year.
Yeah,
I saw that.
But um,
that was very unusual for the area.
Yeah,
like spring,
the winter,
it's more like just constant cold,
dreary,
rainy.
But I'm okay with that.
Like I walk out in the sun in la here
and I'm like,
fuck this shit.
Like I'm,
I'm look how white I am.
Look at this.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't want that.
You love the overcast skies.
I love the rain.
Do you love reasons to be depressed?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't need a reason to be depressed.
I'll be depressed no matter where the
fuck I am.
My surroundings might as well at least a
reflected.
Um,
you get used to the weather out here,
you get used to this son.
But I'll tell you one time I lived,
I used to live in Palmdale.
Oh,
did just so I Kinda,
I kinda understand the climate a little
bit that places a bit mathy.
Yeah.
Palm Dale gets a bit messy.
It gets a bit messy.
And in and Audi,
there's a lot of in and outs out there.
It seems like main food source be in and
out and then quite methy.
Yeah.
Uh,
I just remember,
you know,
I remember living out there and just
seeing like the,
you know,
it was just like,
we want to live near La,
but yeah.
You know,
we don't really want to pay la prices so
exact.
Homedale and they did just have to
commute every day for an hour,
which if you see it in the morning,
I drove up there once real early in the
morning.
I was driving up towards Bakersfield and
it was like,
boy,
I want to say like before dawn.
So it was about five 30 in the morning
and the amount of people coming towards
la from way past bakersfield was fucking
stunning.
Like stunning.
Like I really had no idea.
And it's people that can't afford
housing in La and so they commute and
they commute and they have to get up
really early in the morning to do it
because at five 30 in the fucking
morning,
it's bumper to bumper traffic on the
five.
It's nuts,
man.
Like yeah,
I ain't never seen anything like it when
you,
you just go,
oh my God.
Like this is something that I didn't
even realize was an issue.
All those people that can't afford to
live in La and they drive down and it's
a lot of fucking people that live out
there and drive down here for work a
lot.
They should just build it.
They should put in some high speed rail
and just fucking with it,
talking about doing more affordable
housing along the way for people to just
establish these artificial communities.
But there's a lot of resistance to that.
People that live in that area don't want
those areas developed.
Who the fuck knows?
Now we're developers.
Now we're talking.
When we're talking to Melvin,
we talked about,
and we talk about Jesus.
We talked about bossy and we talked
about waffles.
Does anything we should talk about land
development.
Same thing.
We should take back what we said today.
I thought,
I don't feel bad.
I feel,
I feel pretty good.
I'm pretty good about it.
I'm not,
I don't feel like there's anything that
was said that needs to be like,
oh,
we better revoke that.
People take it
the wrong way or so.
You definitely are going to fuck them.
There's nothing you can do about that.
Nope.
But it is what it is.
Uh,
if people want to see your youtube
videos,
your channel is still the amazing
atheist.
That's right.
Or they can check out my podcast,
a drunken peasants,
and that is the podcast.
No matter what Bill Maher says,
your podcasts is essentially the
podcast.
It's sunk.
Milo.
That is wasn't mine.
I mean,
well,
Milo Sunk Milo more than anyone else
did,
but thanks dude.
Let's do this more often.
All right,
cool.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Bye everybody.
See you.
[inaudible].